[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct vous le voyez sur ces images
prises du capitole à washington dc la
capitale des états unis
la capitale des états unis qui va vivre
aujourd'hui un événement historique vous
allez le vivre vous même avec nous en
direct sur figaro live et sur youtube
l'investiture du président élu joe biden
qui va devenir le 46e président des
états unis
une cérémonie qui marque donc la fin la
fin de l'ère donald trump est justement
à propos de donald trump
je vous propose qu'on se rende tout de
suite en direct de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique pour voir ce qui s'y passe
avec adrien jaulmes bonjour adrien vous
êtes le correspondant du figaro à
washington vous êtes évidemment en
direct depuis la capitale américaine
dans quelques minutes toutes les caméras
seront braquées sur joe biden et sa vice
présidente à venir kamala harris un
grand absent à cette cérémonie on en a
beaucoup parlé c'est évidemment donald
trump qui a dit qu'il n'assisterait pas
à cette investiture de son successeur
donald trump qui a quitté la maison
blanche un peu plus tôt ce matin il est
où à cette heure ci dessous donald trump
il est où cet ancien locataire désormais
de la maison blanche
il est en vol en direction de la floride
il les quittait maison blanche peu à peu
près à peu près 8 heures ce matin à bord
de l'hélicoptère présidentiel il a
survolé washington il est passé au
dessus du congrès où se dérouler comme
vous l'avez indiqué les la cérémonie
d'investiture de joe biden et il a
rejoint la balle à la base d'andrews
dans le maryland pas très loin de
washington où il a prononcé une
allocution avant de s'embarquer avant
d'embarquer à bord du boeing
présidentiel à destination de la floride
il est donc de palm beach précisément
pour retrouver donc sa maison son son
son sa villa
amara logo qu'est lesquelles quel est
son programme du jour qu'est-ce qu'elle
a prévu de faire aujourd'hui pour cette
journée assez particulière même très
particulière pour lui dans quelques
minutes il ne sera plus président des
états unis
en fait son programme il là il a déjà
commencé son programme c'est berry
donald trump qui est qui un président
qui ne nous fait pas beaucoup de choses
comme comme les autres qui a refusé de
2,8 d'assister à la cérémonie deux
navettes et des autres joe biden a eu de
son coût a organisé une petite cérémonie
pour lui de son côté où il s'est adressé
à une petite foule qui était venu
l'accueillir à la venue le saluer à sur
la base aérienne et il est possible
qu'il prononce une allocution à son
arrivée en floride
mais le avant tout ce qu il faut s qui
est ce qu'il faut remarquer c'est que
trump a prononcé des mots qui est un peu
inhabituel cette fois ci il a rendu
hommage aux victimes de victimes de la
pandémie nice qui avait été passé peu
fréquent dans ses discours des derniers
mois il a même salué il n'a pas prononcé
une seule fois le nom de thomas hayden
mais il a quand même salué la nouvelle
administration à laquelle il a souhaité
bonne chance donc il ya eu quand même
tonalité qui étaient un peu différentes
de de celui de donald trump de ces
derniers mois on va revenir à washington
délaissé palm beach en floride et et
donald trump
c'est une cérémonie on le sait qu'il est
placé sous très haute sécurité avec un
dispositif massif
il y a une dizaine de milliers de
soldats de la garde républicaine
déployée dans la ville qui est devenu on
peut le dire un véritable camp retranché
quelle est l'atmosphère sur place c'est
une ville morte
allez tout et avenue du centre est un
immense périmètre qui inclut le national
mall qui est cette grande esplanade qui
qui englobe le mémorial lincoln devant
les ponts d'obélix du mémorial de george
washington la maison blanche la
pennsylvanie qui n'est relié au congrès
le congrès la cour suprême c'est en fait
tout le centre de la capitale est
entouré avec des barrières des plots en
empêcher les voitures les voitures
bélier ou des voitures piégées
d'approché et
de sécurité d'immenses en fait il n'y a
pas de public et le public a été priés
de regarder les événements à la
télévision donc ses tubes ses boutons de
gilles de ses boutons une vie
complètement déserte
aux états unis on envisageait qu' il y
ait des des possibles émeutes ou en tout
cas que c'est capital soit de nouveau
attaqué comme ce fut le cas le 6 janvier
pour le capitole à washington qu est ce
qu est ce qu il en est là bas des
aidants c'est dans ces états de ses
mesures de sécurité
il ya eu des mesures de sécurité qui ont
été prises à peu près dans toutes les
capitales des 50 états de l'union
il ya eu effectivement dans les dents
les jours et la semaine qui a suivi la
manifestation qui a tourné à l'émeute et
qui a investi le capital de washington
beaucoup de rumeurs sur les réseaux
sociaux de rouler ou les plates formes
de groupes communiquent les divers
groupes des divers groupes extrémistes
et qui ont appelé à se soulever à
investir ses capitole donc la plupart
des gouverneurs au coût des mesures de
sécurité ont mobilisé leurs cartes
nationales et finalement le et
finalement les incidents n'ont pas eu
lieu mais c'est toujours c'est toujours
pareil c'est à dire qu'on a on a
beaucoup reproché à la police de la
police de washington et à celle du
capitole de ne ne pas avoir et des
mesures et des dispositions adéquates
avant le avant la manifestation de
donald trump organisé par donald trump
le 6 janvier et ensuite on l'a un peu on
leur a reproché de sur-réagir est
effectivement possible mais c'est
toujours plus facile de le dire après
coup que le moment des événements on le
voit en ce moment sur sur les images que
nous diffusions en direct sur son figaro
l'avait sur youtube c'est l'arrivée au
fur et à mesure des invités qui
s'installe sur les marches de ce
capitole à washington où va ce avoir
lieu cette investiture et de kamala
harris et de joe biden en tant que 46e
président des états unis
ils sont sur le point je crois d'arrivée
kamala harris et et joe biden ils ont
d'ailleurs déjà débuté les festivités
depuis ce matin on va dire ça comme ça
je crois que joe biden était en famille
dans une église de washington pour
assister à une messe qu en est il
oui après festivités c'est un bien grand
mot encore une fois c'est une et c'est
une ville complètement déserte et qui
est qui et qui mise un important
bouclage sécuritaire oui joe biden à joe
biden a assisté à une messe catholique
puisqu'il est catholique à laquelle il
était présent aussi à la plupart des
baies des principales figures politiques
américaines puisque il y avait mitch
mcconnell qui était le précédent chef de
la majorité républicaine au sénat
l'événement de ces pelosi la présidente
de la chambre des représentants
en fait la plupart de la plupart de
l'establishment américain était présent
à 7 à cette cérémonie c'était aussi de
façon vous n'êtes pas totalement
anecdotique la l'église dans laquelle
avaient eu lieu les obsèques tonnes qui
après son assassinat
et donc c'était là c'était là le premier
événement officiel auquel n'assistait
joe biden pendant cette journée
il a soigneusement étendue que donald
trump et philippe prononcé son
allocution est embarqué à bord de son
appareil pour se rendre à se rendre à
l'église
merci beaucoup adrien jambes ce pur
c'est pour ces éclairages ces précisions
sur ce début de ces festivités relatives
et puis sur ce que devient donald trump
pour cette journée aujourd'hui
merci encore d'avoir été en direct avec
nous depuis depuis la capitale
américaine
je rappelle que vous êtes le
correspondant du figaro à washington
et on peut suivre évidemment les récits
que vous faites des élections
américaines et de la suite des
événements avec joe biden dans les pages
du figaro et sur lefigaro.fr
merci encore philippe gelie je me tourne
vers vous merci d'être en direct avec
nous vous êtes directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du figaro éditorialiste de
politique étrangère on l'a vu il ya des
barrières sur des kilomètres dans la
capitale la gare garde nationale est en
nombre
il n'y a pas de public non plus pour
assister à cet événement qui d'habitude
enfin sollicite la foule pour venir
acclamer le futur président
l'heure n'est pas à la fête on va dire
où certains diront que la fête est
gâchée
est ce que la cérémonie sera grandiose
malgré tout
il ya les grandioses le restera
probablement assez télévisuelle puisque
pour la grande majorité du public bien
sûr c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on
regarde chez soi la télévision alors il
ya pour barack obama en 2009 il y avait
presque deux millions de personnes sur
le môle cette esplanade qu'a décrite
adrien pour donald trump vous souvenez
de la polémique à 4 ans sur la plus
grande foule jeu de toute l'histoire des
états unis mais qui en fait était
estimée à environ 500 700 mille
personnes cette fois ci on a planté deux
cent mille drapeau sur le môle drapeau
américain et drapeaux des états qui y
seront là pour symboliser ce public
absent absent pour cause de kovy d'un
bien sûr il faut le préciser c'est pas
caractère complètement chaotiques de
toute la période de transition depuis
l'élection du 3 novembre jusqu'à
l'invasion du congrès le 6 janvier on
pourrait en conclure que et le fait que
donald trump est refusé d'assister à la
l'investiture de son successeur on
pourrait en conclure que c'est la cause
de du côté très particulier de cette
investiture mais le principal
la principale raison c'est le co vide et
le fait que cette nouvelle
administration tient absolument à
montrer l'exemple puisque l'un des
premiers décrets que va signer joe biden
cet après midi enfin dans la soirée pour
nous ce rajustement d'imposer le port du
masque dans tous les établissements dans
tous les bâtiments fédéraux ainsi que
dans les transports inter états puisque
c'est ça qui ressort de la
responsabilité du du chef de la
fédération ne peut pas légiférer à la
place des états en leur sein mais il met
tout ce qui concerne plus d'un état
relève du fédéral donc il va imposer le
port du masque
ce qui va sans doute déplaire à beaucoup
de supporteurs de trump alors on sert le
pays est sous haute tension c'est un
pays aussi profondément divisés que les
donald trump et que va devoir gouverner
joe biden il souhaite d'ailleurs
rétablir l'unité nationale c'est
d'ailleurs la thématique de
donner à cette investiture est ce qu'il
peut y parvenir en clair comment ça
c'est la question à 10 millions de
dollars
si j'avais la réponse je serais
probablement promu à la maison blanche
comme conseiller du président il va
essayer
il hérite d'un pays vraiment en morceaux
extrêmement de diviser extrêmement
tendue que unis si tu as une situation
quasi insurrectionnelle pour certaines
couches de la population
donc c'est vrai que c'est très difficile
le premier geste symbolique que vous
avez évoqué avec adrien d'avoir invité à
cette messe les dirigeants des deux
partis dans les deux chambres
donc y compris kevin mccarthy quai comme
le chef de la minorité républicaine à la
chambre qui a été un des animateurs de
la contestation du vote jusqu'au bout
qui a amené 197 élus républicains a voté
contre la certification des résultats
électoraux tout ça il ya moins de 15
jours et qui aujourd'hui accepte ce
geste d'unité en venant dans une église
bon bien sûr la démocratie américaine
est placée sous sous l'autorité suprême
d'un dieu quel que soit le nom qu'on lui
donne
mais il ya quand même on prête serment
sur la bible on fait des prières avant
les séances du congrès ont fait des
prières avant le conseil des ministres
où la réunion de cabinet donc c'est
quelque chose
la religion à une place centrale au
milieu de la république américaine et ce
geste de dub hayden c'est vraiment un
geste pour essayer de tendre la main aux
représentants de l'opposition et de dire
je veux donner un nouveau style à ma
façon de gouverner
on y reviendra sur sa façon de gouverner
et ce qu'il envisage de faire en détail
un peu plus tard dans au cours de ce
direct je me tourne vers vous maintenant
vincent joly bonjour merci également
d'être en direct avec nous est grand
reporter au figaro magazine
on disait washington est barricadé en ce
moment à adrien jeu nous a dit que
c'était une ville comme à siéger en tout
cas ultra protégée pour éviter un nouvel
assaut éventuellement une nouvelle
attaque de la part de pro trump de
produits dalle trump de partisante
donald trump
une cérémonie dont qui se déroule dans
un contexte très tendu c'est aussi la
conséquence de la tacc du capitole du 6
janvier dernier les américains comme le
monde entier on se souvient ont vécu cet
événement comme comme un traumatisme on
va dire vous vous y étiez vous avez vécu
de l'intérieur l'assaut de ce capital de
ce capitole qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
frappé quelle image vous garderez de cet
assaut et de cet événement grave on peu
difficile un désolé une seule image sur
ce qui a été une journée de toute façon
exceptionnelle qui a commencé par un
chant du cygne du président et qui s'est
terminée avec effectivement une foule
qui à mon sens en tout cas de ce que
j'ai vu le matin même jusqu'aux os
au moment où les premières portes ont
cédé n'avait à mon sens a prévu de
prendre la seule capitale ou en tout cas
d'aller aussi loin mais si je devais
retenir une image c'est une photo qu'on
n'a pas publié dans le figaro magazine
d'ailleurs malheureusement d'un
manifestant pro trump qui était là et il
était venu en habit de soldats
confédérés qui discutaient très très
calmement dans la petite rotonde du
sénat donc on voit d'ailleurs c'est une
des salles gelé les gens sont en train
de traverser en ce moment en train de
discuter avec un policier et voilà
c'était au milieu d'une journée d'un
événement très chaotique un moment comme
ça un peu complètement délirant en fait
et est un peu irréel qui résume à mon
sens bien l'événement du capital elle
dit quoi cette attaque de la colère
d'une partie de l'amérique à mon sens
elle dit beaucoup de choses et surtout
que contrairement à ce que certaines
personnes pensent je crois que c'est une
colère qui n'a pas attendu trump pour
n'être c'est une colère profonde
il faut regarder donc pour le figaro
magazine où on était en géorgie qui
était le dernier état où il y avoue se
tenait les et les élections spéciales
qui ont donné aux démocrates leur deux
derniers sénateur kyl qui leur confère
un contrôle du sénat limité mais tout de
même une égalité à 50 50
c'est une émission si c'est encore
emportées à quelques milliers de voix
il faut voir le profil de ces gens qui
ont envahi capitale je pense notamment à
cette femme
achetez baby 35 ans une vétéran de
l'armée qui avaient voté obama d' deux
fois il faut regarder le profil de cette
femme elle s'est donc si c'est fait deux
tués par un policier dans l'enceinte du
capit exactement et le profil de cette
femme c'est une femme donc il y avait
même dédié sa vie à servir son pays qui
avaient voté obama deux fois qui a voté
trump qui est qui est tellement en
colère qui elle a quand même voulu sans
le dire presque à sa famille à partir à
washington pour pour exprimer à la fois
son soutien à celui qu'elle considère
comme le héros de ces problèmes et en
même temps sa profonde colère alors
c'est la colère qui apportait donald
trump au pouvoir il ya quatre ans est ce
que cette colère s'éteindra avec avec le
départ de donald trump et l'arrivée de
john dryden
je ne pense pas il suffit de voir si
vous voulez donc c'est vrai qu'on
assiste à un moment à
certaines tête du parti républicain je
pense notamment à mitch mcconnell qui a
donc eu pour la première fois hier admis
que les manifestants avaient été
provoqués par donald trump
voilà qui fait un de certaines personnes
qui font six millions d'unités
je pense notamment à d'autres
républicains qui eux ne démordent pas en
ce moment il ya toute une histoire avec
une nouvelle représentante en vue de
couvrir l'arrivée de bob bill et hillary
clinton bill clinton ancien président
des états unis et hillary clinton qui
était on se souvient candidate à
l'élection présidentielle américaine il
ya quatre ans face à donald trump
je vous laisse terminer vincent oui non
et je voulais juste évoqué cette
nouvelle membre de la chambre des
représentants élus de nantes 14e
district de géorgie si je ne me trompe
pas c'est mon ami c'est green
freinons marjorie jeu là pour le coup je
ne suis plus sûr mais qui voit là dans
le sillage de la tête du capitole ne
démord pas et manifestent ce qu'on
pourrait appeler presque un tropisme de
base voilà a toujours contesté les
résultats des élections et même à dire
que le 21 janvier elle lancera une
procédure d' impeachment contre joe
biden donc tout ça évidemment très
fantasque en même temps c'est une partie
de ses électeurs de donald trump et
supporters de donald trump cette
élection leur a été volé il estime que
les résultats ont été faussés oui et
surtout si on regarde certains récents
sondages je pense notamment à un sondage
de la chaîne nbc sur les sympathisants
et votants républicain on a des scores
absolument hallucinant de 70 à 80 %
d'après nbc de sympathisants
républicains qui pense le donald trump
assez correctement comportés
y compris dans le sillage de capital
était quand même une compil
conspirationnistes notoire c'est à dire
elle défend kyo hanon et tout ça voilà
et elle a été élue en ce moment en
direct sur figaro l'avait sur youtube on
voit l'arrivée d'hillary clinton de bill
clinton
son mari qui vont s'installer donc sur
les marches de du capitole pour assister
à l'investiture de joe biden qui
deviendra ainsi le 46e président des
états unis
merci beaucoup vincent joly pour votre
intervention je rappelle que vous êtes
grand reporter au figaro magazine et je
recommande à ce sujet votre reportage
extraordinaire au coeur d'une amérique
déchirée paru dans le dernier numéro du
magazine est en ligne évidemment sur
lefigaro.fr pour les abonnés premium du
journal merci encore vincent joly je me
tourne vers vous philippe gelie un
internaute sur youtube et qui regarde en
ce moment notre émission et je l'en
remercie
nous dit il s'appelle alex il nous
demande joe biden a tout de même 78
ira-t-il seulement au bout de son mandat
sur c'est une question qui est posée
c'est le président le plus âgé au moment
de son investiture de toute l'histoire
américaine
donc c'est pas complètement indifférent
bien sûr ce qui d'ailleurs conduit à
mettre les obama qui arrive philippe on
a vu les mouches et juste avant obama on
a vu les lébous vous arrive en fait mort
par ordre de président de leur
présidence clinton bush obama dont vous
disais qu'il allait évidemment aller
jusqu'au bout de son mandat en jeu
ça dépend de sa santé son état de santé
un avis souligner c'est que
naturellement sa mère
le projecteur est une attention accrue
sur sa colistière ça veut désormais
vice-présidente kamala harris qui est
une jeune sénatrice certaine manière
elle a 56 ans n'a qu'un mandat du sénat
à son actif et elle n'est pas une figure
politique complètement connu la
déposition elle a eu des positions en
californie lorsqu'elle était internet
général c'est à dire l'équivalent du
ministre de la justice qui étaient
plutôt fermes en termes de sécurité de
que de soutien de la police etc
en même temps depuis la campagne de 2020
elle a pris des positions assez à gauche
du du parti démocrate donc on ne sait
pas trop à quoi s'en tenir à son sujet
évidemment c'est aussi grâce à haisnes
que joe biden a remporté cette élection
probablement le ticket en ces débats
table parce que on a coutume de dire que
le colistier ne change rien à la chance
d'être élu ou pas d'un du candidat
principal bon dans le cas de joe biden
peut-être peut-être est-ce vrai
peut-être aussi s 1 cela a pu aussi
retenir des gens de voter pour elle
d'avoir parce que c'est la première
femme qui accède à cette fonction
donc il se peut qu'une partie de
l'électorat ne soit pas encore
complètement converti à l'idée de que
qu'une
une vice-présidente puisse plus accéder
au pouvoir sans être élu directement
elle a des origines
comme vous le savez à la fois jamaïcaine
indienne alors on a dit c'est une
afro-américaine donc l oral obtient
l'aide à obtenir le vote afro américain
est en réalité
joe biden a eu le vote afro américains
pendant les primaires avant d'avoir
choisi kamala harris
elle est aussi asiatiques par sa mère
puisqu'elle sa mère est indienne était
indienne est décédé bon je crois que on
a beau on a trop on a trop insisté sur
ses dimensions là je pense que sa
personnalité est attirante pour beaucoup
de jeunes américains elle représente
l'amérique mixité raciale sociale une
ascension sociale qu'elle ne doit qu'à
elle même
je suis pas sûr que enfin à mon avis le
principal facteur de l'élection de bill
dann site quand même donald trump et le
vote de rejet envers donald trump
on accueille maintenant sur le sur le
plateau et on est ravi de recevoir luc
benoît à la guillaume merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes historien spécialiste des
états unis et auteur d'une thèse sur les
discours d'investiture du président
américain
alors on l'a vu tout à l'heure que joe
biden ne prononcera pas son discours
devant un parterre de citoyens
américains devant une foule comme c'est
le cas d'habitude c'est pour comme le
disait philippe gelie des raisons
sanitaires d'abord du fait du coc vide
il fera face à un parterre de près de
200000 drapeau américain
c'est un dispositif on va dire qui
permet de se dire que chaque drapeau
correspond à un individu un citoyen
américain
chaque drapeau symbolisera effectivement
les spectateurs qui n'ont pas pu se
rendre sur place ce dispositif inédit
c'est quand même une vision un peu
particulière lui benoît à la guillaume
on a l'impression qu'en fait aujourd'hui
on a les symboles de la démocratie à
washington mais on n'a pas le peuple
ben oui bon pour des raisons sanitaires
l'évidente à me dire qu'au bon
comme vous le disiez à l'instant le la
pandémie fait que l'administration byden
pouvait pas faire autrement
ce d'autant plus que bon elle envoie
aussi un message politique de prudence
qui tranche avec l'attitude de
l'administration précédente vis-à-vis de
du port du masque de la distanciation
sociale etc
donc c'est clair qu'il ya à la fois une
nécessité sanitaire et en même temps il
ya un message politique de rupture par
rapport aux latitudes et au comportement
de l'administration trump vis-à-vis des
précautions nécessaires à prendre ce ce
discours qu'on attend de joe biden qui
arrivera après celui de kamala harris
williams le discours de cameron prête
serment
cela parle c'est au maïdan excusez moi
donc à propos de ce discours de joe
biden il devrait selon ses conseillers
duré vingt 20 à 30 minutes est ce que
c'est une durée on va dire normal dans
un discours présidentiel américain oui
oui 20 pour tout cas pour les dans la
période contemporaine oui voilà c'est un
disque une longueur standard
voilà c'est des discours qui sont qui
sont assez calibrer les
les conseillers qui écrivent les dix
courses et préparer un mois un mois et
demi à l'avancé
il ya toute une équipe qui fait une
première version qui est relu par
diverses personnes et annoté par le
président d'abord ils relisent les
discours précédents parce qu'il ya quand
même un genre est une tradition donc il
s'inspire un peu de ce qui a été fait
précédemment et la longueur elle est
relativement standardisés parce que bon
d'avoir parce qu'il ya un programme des
cérémonies et puis aussi parce que bon
il faut pas que ça soit trop court pour
qu'ils puissent quand même a donné une
première impression peuple américain en
même temps c'est beaucoup moins long
qu'un discours sur l'état de l'union on
aurait tout un programme législatif qui
prendrait plus de temps
le discours a pour thème l'unité joe
biden devrait parler de l'importance de
rassembler les américains en temps de
crise il s'est posé en rassembleur
d'ailleurs pendant toute sa campagne
en quoi cette posture de rassembleur
finalement est-elle si différente de ses
prédécesseurs ce qu'on va retrouver
cette unité dans son discours est ce que
tous les autres présidents ne l'ont pas
eu ah bah oui ça c'est un grand
classique à ceux inhérents à ce genre de
discours oui enfin pas disons qu'en tout
cas bon voilà le
disons que le genre de discours veut que
après la l'opposition de la campagne on
se présente en président de tous les
américains c'est vrai que trump a un peu
dérogé à ça parce qu'il a parlé de
carnage américain de façon quand même
très exagérées néanmoins il s'est quand
même plié au fait qu' il ne dénonçaient
pas le parti opposé dans discours
d'investiture
ce ça on ne peut pas faire ça dans un
discours d'investiture à on peut on se
présente forcément la personne qui est
le président pour tous les américains il
avait devancé tout l'establishment en
fait y compris son propre parti ouais il
avait fait un discours anti devant le
parterre de des élus et en leur disant
le pouvoir je vous le promets je
l'europe
oui mais d'un discours très agressif oui
mais bon
donc c'est sûr que le voilà le thème de
l'unité nationale ça va prolonger ce
qu'il a dit dans sa campagne ou des
lignes qu'il allait guérir l'amérique
sigle en anglais
bon c'est quand même aussi un peu un
grand classique de ce type de discours
malgré tout alors après évidemment les
circonstances donc c'est compliqué
beaucoup de donald trump je crois qu'il
est en train d'arriver en floride je
crois qu'on devrait avoir les images de
son avion qui atterrit en ce moment
du côté de palm beach si on a les images
on voulait montrera
philippe gelie donald trump il avait été
élu sur son projet make guen on s'en
souvient évidemment est parvenu et les
promesses ont elles été tenues
un certain nombre de promesses ont été
tenues
du moins il a essayé de tenir le est ce
que l'amérique les plus grandes et plus
forte aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était il
ya quatre ans ça c'est un débat par
essence politique si vous êtes pro tram
vous pensez qu oui et donc il ya 74
millions d'américains qui ont plutôt été
enclins à répondre oui lors de
l'élection du 3 novembre
et puis il ya 81 millions d'américains
qui ont répondu non et c'est beaucoup
dans les deux cas c'est un record c'est
à dire jamais trappes a dit tout à
l'heure jamais un président en exercice
n'avait obtenu pour son sa seconde
élection autant de voix que moi il a
raison mais jamais aucun président
n'avait obtenu autant de voix que bill
dann or on voit bien que baydan ne
suscite pas un enthousiasme déchaînés et
co vide ou paco vide
au moins cette situation d'aujourd'hui
va nous éviter une polémique à laquelle
on n'aurait pas échappé qui ont été sur
la taille de la foule de baden bien
entendu si foule il y avait eu au moins
on va échapper à ça mais on peut dire
sans trop se tromper que c'est pas
tellement biden qui a électrisé on a vu
mike pence
arrivé avec sa femme un évident
l'ex vice président des états unis
encore il est pour l'instant quelques
minutes encore et qui assiste lui à
cette inauguration cette cérémonie
d'investiture
philippe oui on est au bout de mes
peines c'est un personnage qui était
particulièrement discret pendant le
mandat de donald trump il a en fait
beaucoup fait parler de lui ces
dernières semaines alors particulier
après les attaques du capitole qu'est ce
qu'il faudra retenir de ces quatre
années à la vice présidence des états
unis derrière l'ombre de donald trump
il fait partie de ces personnages qui
sont réveillés tout à fait à la fin du
mandat de 30 qui ont passé quatre ans à
tous lui passer comme on pourrait le
dire d'un
d'un adolescent capricieux et parfois
donald trump s'est vraiment comporter de
cette manière là comme un être
capricieux narcy narcissique et impulsif
à l'instar de mitch mcconnell qui on
voit aujourd'hui jouer le jeu des
institutions est allé à la main sacs aux
côtés de joe biden mais c'est le même
profil c'est à dire que ce sont des
membres de l'establishment qui ont été
d'abord je pense d'une certaine manière
fasciné par trump par sa façon de
conquérir le pouvoir de d'un excès le
parti républicain et qu'ils y ont
littéralement tout passé et c'est
d'autant plus étonnant dans le cas de
mike pence que c'est un homme qui ça qui
se prévaut de convictions chrétiennes
très très forte de préceptes moraux très
rigide qui ne qui ne veut jamais se
trouvait dans une pièce avec une femme
sans la présence de sa propre épouse
qu'il appelle mauvaise mère enfin je
veux dire c'est quelqu'un qui est
quelqu'un vous l'avez décrit quand
j'avais écrit un portrait de lui
depuis washington comme ce genre un
enfant de choeur qui essaye d'être plus
plus plus parfait que le prêtre bon
alors il avait cette espèce de panoplies
de il se draper dans des pouvoirs moreau
très très élevé mais quand il ya eu des
scandales autour de donald trump
il les a toujours pardonner balayé les
accusations d'agression sexuelle la
cassette ou train de se vanter lui même
de saisir les femmes à la partie intime
voilà par la partie d'un type vraiment
tout ça ce ce bon chrétien de mike pence
là totalement absous au nom du réel de
son de sa realpolitik à lui et de ses
intérêts politiques
donc je pense que pour une grande partie
pour une grosse moitié des américains
il est marqué du sceau de donald trump
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
est-ce qu'il a un avenir politique
aujourd'hui je miserais pas grand chose
à court terme
c'est quelqu'un qui avait qui étaient
quand même sorti d'ing
d'un poste de gouverneur de toute façon
qu'il a qui était fini pour lui il ne
pouvait plus se représenter
il avait surtout fait parler de lui
avant la présidence de donald trump pour
avoir signé une loi qui a par la suite
été déclarée inconstitutionnelle et qui
est autorisé à certaines mesures de
discrimination au nom de la foi non au
nom de la religion il avait signé cette
loi dans son bureau de gouverneur
entouré de deux moines en robe de bure
et de religieuses donc c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui portait sa religion sur sa
manche comme on dit je pense que il a
perdu un peu en en sainteté et en
crédibilité en a 4 ans de données avec
avec son épouse ils vont s'installer
donc sur cette estrade le dit c'est un
peu racheté à la fin on peut dire
puisqu'il s'est comporté en présidant
oui quand donald trump a disparu c'est à
dire quand donald trump a cessé de
répéter tous les jours qu'ils avaient
gagné une élection qu'en réalité il
n'avait pas gagné et qu'il s'est terrée
dans la maison blanche et qui sait plus
occupé que de jouer au golf et de signer
les derniers des dernières grâce
présidentielle
à ce moment-là byden à partir du moment
où le 6 janvier où il a contre l'avis de
trains validé l'élection en faisant
valoir qu'il n'avait pas le pouvoir de
ne pas valider l'élection d'ali ce qui
est absolument vrai il s'est dit il
n'avait pas le pouvoir tout simplement
à ce moment là il a eu une attitude un
peu présidentielle à la place de trains
pas en allant par exemple dernièrement
salué les troupes qui est protégé le
capital on le voit donc à l'image my
peines bientôt ex vice président des
états unis
c'est important qu'ils soient là
finalement parce que train pétrole et
rien ne peut pas admettre qu'il a perdu
ça peut pas ça dépasse les capacités de
sa psychologie il peut pas formulé cette
phrase là j'ai perdu mes peines fait le
lien d'une certaine manière la
transmission du pouvoir passe par trépas
peines et pour un certain nombre de
républicains raisonnables qui respecte
les institutions de leur pays et c'est
la majorité
c'est important qu'il soit là manon sur
youtube qui est une internaute qui nous
suit en ce moment je l'en remercie qui a
ce message on va dire assez assez durs
my penza au moins l'intelligence d'être
présent beaucoup plus intelligent que
son clone de président bon ça fait
partie ça reflète un peu les
commentaires que nous avons pour
certains internautes en tout cas depuis
le début de cette diffusion on le voit
barack obama et sa femme michelle obama
sur les marches de cette estrade du
capitole qui va servir à assister un pur
c'est officiel et ces personnalités à
l'investiture du 46e président des états
unis joe biden et dont on attend
l'arrivée avec sa future vice-présidente
kamala harris et benoît à la guillaume
je me tourne vers vous parce que on a
beaucoup parlé effectivement de 7,2 de
cette capitale aujourd'hui qui vit un
événement on va dire festive mais qui
est teinté quand même d'une chape de
sécurité massive avec on l'a beaucoup vu
ces gardes nationaux qui ont été
déployés sur la ville on parle de 25
mille soldats qui sont réparties pour
surveiller sécuriser cette capitale
aujourd'hui en amont des cérémonies et
pendant la cérémonie
on a des questions effectivement il ya
beaucoup d'internautes qui nous
s'interroge sur cette garde nationale
dont on a vu certains soldats d'ailleurs
faire la sieste dans le capitole il ya
quelques jours lors de leur arrivée sur
zone on va dire quel est le rôle de
cette garde nationale et quelle est son
histoire parce qu'on n'a pas ce type de
d'armé on va dire en france c'est vrai
que c'est on n'a pas l'équivalent exact
disons que c'est une sorte de réserve
militaire composée de volontaires donc
se souder les membres feront d'héritiers
puis le fond sinon voilà ils passent une
partie de leur temps à l'armée en fait
enfin dans la garde nationale un peu
comme la réserve les réservistes chez
nous la spécificité c'est d'une part que
c'est sous le double contrôle des états
fédérés et de l'état fédéral donc ça
peut être mobilisée par le gouverneur
d'un état mais aussi par l'état fédéral
donc il ya sept cet élément de double
commande alors l'origine ces sont les
milices qui existait à la fin du xviiie
siècle où vous aviez une nation de
fermiers de petits paysans qui
cultivaient leurs terres et puis ils
avaient leurs fusils
dans leur grange et quand il y avait
besoin de les mobiliser pour une raison
ou pour une autre
voilà il était actif dans la milice de
l'état l'origine lointaine c'est cesser
ce la formulation du deuxième port
d'armes qui parle de novices milice bien
organisée
voilà et qui sont nécessaires à la
défense des voilà exactement
voilà donc pour cette petite parenthèse
concernant ces soldats qu'on appelle des
soldats à temps partiel ils sont je
crois que 405 faut noter quand même que
l'homme sur le territoire avec une
douzaine ont été renvoyés dans leurs
foyers par le par le fbi à huy qui a
passé en revue leur background fallait
leur engagement politique leurs tweets
leurs réseaux sociaux leurs activités
sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'il craignait que il ya une
infiltration scène rouge c'est la zone
sécurisée aujourd'hui dans washington de
deux des émeutiers de du 6 janvier dans
les effectifs chargés de protéger les
officiels du jour or quand on voit le
l'aréopage de l'ancien président et de
et d'élus lire toute la démocratie
américaine est réunie sur le même
plateau aujourd'hui donc les conditions
de sécurité sont nécessaires
les benoît à la guillaume l'élection
présidentielle américaine a eu lieu le 3
novembre dernier mais le nouveau
président américain ainsi que sa vice
présidente ne prenne officiellement
leurs fonctions à compter du jour de
l'investiture donc aujourd'hui ça fait
près de deux mois et demi plus tard
comme on explique ce timing basse et de
sa date des débuts de
depuis 2 sera existe depuis 200 ans il
jusqu'en 1937 s'était même encore plus
tardif puisque jusqu'en 1900 marfan
voilà c'était le 4 mars un roosevelt a
pris ses fonctions le 4 mars 33
c'était vraiment une transition très
longue qui a été raccourci du coup il
s'agit de alors à l'origine comme c'est
un système d'élection indirects il faut
quand même le temps de compter les voix
de
bon il y avec les chevaux et les
diligences à l'époque donc voilà donc
les les réalités des malades faisait
qu'il fallait un petit peu de temps pour
compter les voix que le collège
électoral se réunissent ça veut dire
qu'on comme c'est pas une élection
directe on peut pas avoir une transition
en deux jours comme dans les pays
européens où en une semaine comme en
france harris et son mari douglas et mof
qui sera je crois comme on va l'appeler
philippe gelie le premier sac en
gentleman et on va le dire comme ça
aussi en français même s'il va falloir
qu'on trouve une forme ça sera peut-être
le mari de la vice président mais oui
c'est marie avec kamala harris en 2014
il a pris un congé sans solde de son
cabinet depuis août dernier pour
soutenir sa sa compagne là il y aurait
un conflit d'intérêts s'il veut rester
avocat donc il s'est mis en retrait de
son cabinet d'avocats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des états unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
obama et son flegme légendaire et son
aisance en n'importe quelle situation et
de nouveaux effets
décontraction on va dire quoi qu'ils ont
fait en selle fils je me trompe pas
c'est quand même
ça rit ça restera dans l'histoire c'est
ces visages masqués resteront dans
l'histoire oui c'est quand même un
spectacle incroyable des tous les héros
du jour sont masqués par admis
invisibles dans les livres d'histoire ça
restera quand même comme une investiture
sans pareil enfin je ne m'en remets à
l'historien mais dans bien sûr bien sûr
c'est alors kamala harris sera la 49e
vice-présidente des etats-unis
c'est la première femme ainsi que la
première personne afro-américaine et
sino américaine d'origine indo
américaines à être élu à la vice
présidente 10 présidence des états unis
à 56 ans il est né d'un père jamaïcain
vous l'aviez dit tout à l'heure philippe
gelie est d'humeur indienne
son parcours son parcours est assez
extraordinaire à cette femme philippe
gelie 1 pour beaucoup c'est son
ascension suscite et correspond à ce
qu'on se fait du rêve américain
oui bien sûr deux parents immigrés donc
lé deuxième génération elle a fait
sensation pendant la campagne des
primaires ou souvenez lors du premier
débat en attaquant assez vivement joe
biden et en lui reprochant d'avoir à
l'époque de la déségrégation scolaire
lorsqu'elle était petite fille d'avoir à
l'époque était opposé à un système de
bus de ramassage scolaire par autobus
qui permettait de 2
à des enfants des quartiers défavorisés
d'aller dans des écoles qui étaient de
bonnes écoles et d'essai grecque
enfin des ségrégué disant voilà je
cherchais le mot et elle l'avait attaqué
assez vivement en lui disant c'était
d'ailleurs un peu théâtral c'était cette
petite fille monsieur byden c'était moi
etc
il s'est défendu assez assez mal
d'ailleurs à l'époque sur lefigaro.fr
incarne au figaro.fr quelle joie de
revoir cette amérique et ses vraies
valeurs sont les dirigeants du congrès
qui arrive de la chambre des
représentants
alors on parlait tout à l'heure
évidemment de cette transmission entre
donald trump et joe biden qui va avoir
les dents quelques minutes on voit joe
biden est arrivé avec sa femme jill
c'est vrai que cette question que vous
posez qu'il provient d'un internaute
anonyme est intéressant parce que tout
le monde se la pose c'est une question
qui revient aussi dans de nombreux films
américains comment va se passer la
transmission des codes nucléaires
si donald trump hebeisen ne
s'entretiennent pas ensemble dans le
cadre de la passation de pouvoir une
question intéressante parce qu'elle fait
fantasmer beaucoup de gens oui mais on a
une vision un peu simpliste des choses
c'est en fait un général qui accompagne
partout le président est qui et qui
possède la valise avec les codes
nucléaires
il faut pas s'imaginer que ce site
serait et et donald trump en personne
qui aurait confié sur un bout de papier
à joe biden les codes nucléaires
il ya toute une série de protocoles qui
inclut d'ailleurs je pense plus que des
codes des des empreintes d'iris de enfin
sécurité de sécurit nombreuses et le
président n'est pas le seul à pouvoir
actionner ne peut pas actionné tous
seule larme nectaire
on va laisser vivre ces images de joe
biden et on peut on peut s'interroger on
peut imaginer à ce qu'il peut se passer
dans sa tête en ce moment est
probablement une pensée pour pour son
fils disparu et qu'il a rendu hommage
certes c'est surtout l'aboutissement
d'une vie entière pour joe biden c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est en politique
depuis 50 ans qui a toujours rêvé il a
été le plus jeune sénateur il a été élu
avant même l'âge minimum pour siéger qui
est de 30 ans il avait 29 ans et
quelques lorsqu'il a été élu et on sait
qu'il a été tout de suite frappé par ce
terrible drame de l'accident de voiture
de sa première femme dans laquelle elle
décède ainsi que sa petite fille et ses
deux fils sont gravement blessés et ils
s'interrogent d'ailleurs à l'époque sur
la pertinence de rester en politique
mais dès ses premiers pas au sénat il a
l'ambition d'être président il sera
candidat trois fois
quant à free center avec lui petit gars
pouces et voilà on va je sois l'arrivée
de jeunes voire même une des dubaï denis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président élu réside à reading joseph
robinette biden junior et le docteur
gilles bayard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
place
et me courjault madame amy klobuchar
[Applaudissements]
matin la vice présidente élue du congrès
de la place judiciaire si un président
et un vice-président leader de
l'étranger et toute la famille
hayden d'amérique souhaite la bienvenue
cérémonie d'investiture dans quelques
instants
k malajube hayden prêteront serment
solennellement cette série est la
culmination 244 années de démocratie
c'est tellement lequel les leaders
appelé sur cette tribune par un le foie
des américains viennent promettre de
défendre notre différence notre
constitution
devenu trop blasé trop pas coutume et à
ce rituel de passation pour comprendre
véritablement combien c'est une
bénédiction et un privilège d'assister à
ce moment je ne le crois pas il ya deux
semaines lorsque un goût en colère et
violent est entré dans ce temple de la
démocratie cela nous a réveillés quant à
nos responsabilités d'américains c'est
le jour où les états unis ramasse les
morceaux se secoue effet ce que
l'amérique fait à chaque fois vivre
comme une nation solidaire sous le
regard de dieu avec la justice pour tous
si cette cérémonie a lieu ici c'est une
bonne raison lorsque l'icône a donné sa
première fait cette première déclaration
ici le dôme navet qui était
partiellement construits et rincon a
promis de terminer cette construction du
dôme il on le critiquait d'avoir trop
dépensé pour lui pendant la guerre
civile et à cela il a répondu si les
gens voient que le capital continue à
progresser
cela leur montrera que nous avons
l'intention de faire en sorte que
l'union se poursuivent et l'union s'est
poursuivi et nous continuerons à
poursuivre sur ce chemin des lois
importantes ont été adoptées dans ce
bâtiment et nous incombe aujourd'hui pas
simplement les deux leaders que vous
invitez sont aujourd'hui nous incombe à
tous de reprendre la torche de la
démocratie a en tant que flambeau pour
incendier les esprits mais en tant que
force pour le bien
nous célébrons tout ce qui fait
l'amérique les gens ordinaires qui font
des choses extraordinaires pour notre
pays les médecins et les infirmières qui
sont tout comme la ligne de cette
épidémie les responsables les équipes du
capital et nouvelle génération qui se
lève pour la justice et nous célébrons
nouveaux résidents baden qui promet de
restaurer la main des états unis et de
nous amener plus loin nous célébrons si
notre première vice-présidente femmes
asiatiques américaines et
afro-américaine madame kamala harris qui
est aujourd'hui qui arrive après tant
d'autres fans qui ont préparé le chemin
pour elle en vous voyant les enfants
crient vous regarde sauront que tout
cela est possible et c'est ça les etats
unis se ça notre démocratie c'est le
pays du bien
aujourd'hui sur les marches du capitole
et devant ses deux magnifiques parterres
de drapeaux nous nous voulons une fois
de plus à sa cause merci j'ai maintenant
l'honneur de vous présenter sénateurs 4
réactions et tant d'autres optent pour
rendre possible cette cérémonie mon ami
du comité de l'investiture sauta au
congrès bien d'entendre un mouchard
d'intervenir premier discours s'est
impliqué a commencé à s'impliquer
j'aurais dû deviner qu'il y aurait au
moins un tout petit peu de neige
j'avais prévu pas mal de choses
aujourd'hui mais certainement pas la
neige avant de sortir le nez dehors
aujourd'hui en tout cas merci à madame
claude bouchard et aux autres membres du
comité conjoint d'investiture à l'heure
où nous commençons officiellement cette
cérémonie
merci également à nos équipes et nos
partenaires notamment pour la sécurité
de cet événement la façon dont ils ont
géré ces circonstances tout à fait
inédite
il ya quatre ans lorsque j'étais ici je
vous ai rappelé ce qu'avait dit reagan
en 1981 un événement à la fois
disent-ils banal extraordinaire banal
puisque
depuis 1780 nous le connaissons bien et
plus miraculeux tout de même parce que
justement il a lieu tous les quatre ans
depuis cette date 1 ya eu lieu où cette
série a lieu pendant les guerres des
dépressions et aujourd'hui à l'heure de
la pandémie
une fois de plus les trois branches du
gouvernement les trois pouvoirs se
réunissent comme le prévoit la
constitution une fois de plus nous
renouvelons notre engagement à l'égard
de la démocratie pour renforcer et
parfaire l'union les états unis
ce thème une union plus parfaite a été
annoncée par le comité conjoint qui
pensaient que les etats-unis ne
pouvaient tenir leurs promesses et
d'être un exemple pour les autres que si
nous travaillons toujours à être
meilleur que nous l'avons été par le
passé la constitution et la démocratie a
pour définition que le peuple est la
source du gouvernement que le la
population et les citoyens sont la
source du gouvernement
et c'est là qu'intervient l'expression
par faire l'union
les fondateurs n'ont pas dit former une
union parfaite déjà parfaite
ils n'ont pas dit que penser que dans
notre nouveau pays
rien n'aurait être amélioré heureusement
ils ont compris que avancer vers le
mieux que parfaire notre union serait
est la marque d'une belle démocratie les
libertés que nous avons aujourd'hui la
nation qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
n'existe pas simplement parce que cela
s'est fait d'un coup de baguette magique
notre pays a progressé à travers les
difficultés à travers les problèmes pour
toujours s'améliorer et nous sommes
aujourd'hui plus que ce que nous fûmes
autrefois
il attaque contre notre capital ici même
il ya juste deux semaines nous rappelle
qu' un gouvernement qui avec
contre-pouvoir est à la fois fragile et
résilient l'année dernière la pandémie a
mis en difficulté notre société a
demandé de nous d'extraordinaires
sacrifices et nous met encore au défi
aujourd'hui relever ce défi c'est ce
qu'ont fait médecins nos infirmières
tous ceux qui sont en première ligne
aujourd'hui alors je vous parle partout
dans le monde nous sommes regardés
observer notre gouvernement s'est réuni
le congrès les cours sont ici réunis
chaque fois cette cérémonie a lieu il ya
un parti politique est plus heureux
l'autre mais aujourd'hui l'heure n'est
pas à la à la division nous sommes ici
pour célébrer un nouveau début un
nouveau commencement une démocratie
déterminé résolu à se parfaire
est ce que nous recherchons aujourd'hui
pour tous les américains
ce fut un privilège pour moi que d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui merci o'donovan
un ami de longue date président élu va
maintenant monter à la tribune
passe la parole maintenant au révérend
leo'o donovan qui est le prêtre ou le
révérend on va dire qui va faire
l'invocation maintenant normalement
miséricordieux lieu de grâce sacré nous
venons vers toi à genoux mais plus
encore nous venons plein d'espoir et
avec nos yeux levés une nouvelle fois
vers la vision d'une union plus parfaite
dans notre pays si l'union de tous les
citoyens pour promouvoir le bien-être
général et les bénédictions de la
liberté pour nous-mêmes et notre
prospérité
nous sommes ici réunis des gens de
diverses races croyante seule couleur
horizon que nombreux qu'avant dans un
pays plus large que lorsque la prière de
l'investiture de george washington a été
écrite l'archevêque carole à l'époque
avait demandé au créateur d'assister
d'aidé dans un esprit de fortitude et
deux fois
le président des états unis à accomplir
son devoir
aujourd'hui nous confessons l'échec
était le nôtre pour vivre par le passé
selon nos croyances notre vision de
liberté d'égalité pour tous mais plus
encore que par le passé nous sommes
convaincus de l'importance d'aller de
l'avant de d'aider ceux qui sont les
plus défavorisés par menno et ainsi de
devenir une lumière pour le monde de
pouvoir en chacun d'entre nous qui vit
lorsque nous nous tournons vers autrui
la capacité de chérir d'aider les autres
et notamment ceux qui sont le plus en
détresse ou qui ont le plus besoin de
nous cette force s'appelle l'amour
aujourd'hui c'est le patriotisme
américain
je n'ai pas années du pouvoir et de
privilèges mais de l'amoureuse de du
bien commun sans malveillance à l'égard
de quiconque et avec la charité qui
s'adresse à tous nous espérons pour vous
que vous aurez la sagesse du livre de
salomon lorsque salomon demande d'avoir
la capacité de distinguer le bien du
monde
le bien du mal le pape françois rabelais
de l'importance des rêves
nous devons rêver ensemble il dit
chacun isolément nous risquons de voir
des mirages nous dit il des choses qui
n'existent pas les rêves en revanche
sont créé ensemble collectivement soit
avec nous saint mystère de l'amour
alors où nous rêvons ensemble et nous
sous la houlette de notre nouveau
président réconcilier les personnes de
notre pays de réaliser notre rêve de
paix de justice et de vivre la joie qui
n'est que l'amour surabondant pour ta
plus haute
gloire et pour les siècles des siècles
amen
une petite fête qui était bonne
pour la présentation du drapeau l'hymne
national ainsi que les serments
bien entendre donc le révérend léo
donovan qui a donc créé cette prière
avec l'assemblée présente dans les
gradins de ce capital pour l'investiture
de joe biden on le disait tout à l'heure
cette présence de la religion cette
omniprésence de la religion mêlée à la
politique aux etats unis
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
traditionnel lui benoît à la guillaume
et cette invocation que l'on vient
d'entendre et qui précède l'arrivée de
joe biden et son investiture
c'est quelque chose de traditionnel ça
fait partie même on va dire de la
constitution américaine
en tout cas ça fait partie de la
tradition le on parle souvent à ce sujet
de religion civile 1 pour décrire ce ce
type de mélange entre religion et
politique ce qui est assez remarquable
c'est qu'il s'agit de finalement 2-2
d'un appel à dieu mais d un dieu qui est
vague
alors ce monsieur est jésuites à prêtre
catholique qui donne au brouillard
il a cité le pape françois mais sinon ça
aurait pu être un discours prononcé par
un protestant ou même par un rabbin et
parce qu'il s'agit vraiment de dire que
dieu bénisse l'amérique qu'il va
protéger le nouveau président là je vous
coupe permettez moi de vous couper les
boums à la guillaume parce qu'on est
dans un tout autre univers maintenant
c'est l'arrivée de la star on peut dire
lady gaga qui devrait interpréter
l'hymne américain
dans quelques secondes elle était très
attendue cette interprétation est cet
artiste pour cet événement
et
[Musique]
bagdad
non
un toit
[Musique]
non
au mans
et on
mais
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
ans
là
oh
m
[Musique]
étant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un mois
ouais
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interprétation interprétation magistrale
dit philippe gelie en plateau
effectivement pour cette interprétation
de l'hymne américain the star spangled
banner avec un micro en or gold and my
call phones pour lady gaga
c'est aussi votre avis benoît lui benoît
à la guillaume c'est top
l'interprétation de l'hymne américain
était magistral entrer la champions très
bas ce qui n'était pas le cas de beyoncé
lors de la dernière le champion la lnh
était à la chanter en live par donc la
patience et il ya quelques années pour
obama je ne suis pas spécialiste de
champ mais d'après ce que je sais c'est
sensé très difficile à chanter allah de
l'amplitude entre les aigus et les
graves donc ses 107 avère très
différents à chanter tous les chanteurs
le disent et là au moins on à la dose de
glamour qui nous manquait un peu
jusqu'ici n'est pas un geste sont au
drapeau américain
[Applaudissements]
je je peux préciser
est-ce que les micros sont ouverts alors
on vient de voir
andrea hall qui vient faire d'eux les
serments d'allégeance 1 vient de prêter
allégeance au drapeau on va préciser
simplement que cette jeune femme de 28
ans était la première femme noire
promu capitaine des pompiers de
l'histoire du service de secours
incendie de la ville de moncton
la vice présidente
[Applaudissements]
oui soir
puis y élever votre main droite et
répétez après moi moi camelin dbrs jure
solennellement mois calmes à la db jure
solennellement que je soutiendrai
défendre la constitution des états unis
que je soutiendrai défendre la
constitution des états unis contre tous
les ennemis extérieurs et intérieurs
contre les ennemis extérieurs et
intérieurs que je lui fais entière
allégeance je vais en tirer les gens ce
que j'assume cette obligation librement
sans avoir à l'esprit quelques reverte
réserve ou l'intention d'y échapper que
j'accomplirai correctement et fidèlement
les devoirs correspondants à mes futures
fonctions puisse dieu me et des puisse
dieu nous y aider
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voir kamala harris c'est en compagnie de
sonia sotomayor sonia sotomayor qui est
juriste américaine et qui fait partie
des neuf juges de la cour suprême des
etats unis
[Musique]
et un siège de la cour suprême de l'été
venu
été choisi je ne sais pas si c'est par
kamala harris est de même pour
ces serments un comité d'organisation de
la deûle à la cérémonie d'investiture
qu'on a vu président des parcs par amy
klobuchar donc je pense qu'ils ont fait
ça encore en concertation avec les
participants et donc ça y est on va dire
que c'est fait kamala harris vient de
prêter serment elle devient ainsi la
première femme vice-présidente des
etats-unis
alors voit évidemment jennifer lopez et
autres stars très attendus pour cet
événement aujourd'hui qui devrait
interpréter une ou plusieurs chansons au
moins une en tout cas elle est prévue
pour une performance musicale
aujourd'hui en amont de l'investiture de
joe biden
[Musique]
visionnez
les mannes
[Musique]
vainqueurs les faunes yeux tout de new
york
besson
legault suis moi
[Musique]
mais elle avoue manquer
aso lui aient meskaoui à sort des lots
mis aux divers
et cela
rose mais où new way
oh
[Musique]
et cela
eh ouais
et
à temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
muet
vous
ouais
à
[Musique]
oh
et
i
quoi
un coup
nous
debout
enfin si tous genres
[Musique]
pour la nation balancer des missiles
soins
amoureuse mais polluées
me
[Musique]
et voilà c'était jennifer lopez pour une
interprétation d'une chanson
traditionnelle américaine en tout cas
très connu aux états unis en général on
l'entend dans une version un peu plus
rythmée luc benoît à la guillaume je
crois que c'est un classique même de du
répertoire des chansons traditionnelles
américaines
oui alors en fait si j'ai bien écouté je
crois qu'ils en fait c'est un pot-pourri
star qui avait un morceau de la chanson
des slams des irlandais puis un morceau
de maraka de beautiful
c'est un medley un pot pourri en fait et
met effectivement en décelant d'eolane
s'éteint c'est une chanson qui date des
années 30 d'un auteur de voilà de deux
chansons populaires qui s'appelait goût
des gaufriers qui fait partie des
chansons traditionnelles qui sont un
hymne à la nation alors à l'origine
chanson progressiste en fait un outil
gratuit
on remarquera également philippe gelie
je me tourne vers vous que jennifer
lopez a dit quelques mots en espagnol
également
oui bien sûr il faut il faut être
inclusif dans ce genre de cérémonie et
le fait que jennifer lopez soit latino
aide et on assiste au moment crucial de
la cérémonie
joseph byden junior jure solennellement
de m'acquitter loyalement de la charge
de président des états-unis et de faire
tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir pour
préserver protéger et défendre la
constitution des états unis
puisse dieu nous y aider
félicitations monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les etats-unis ont désormais un nouveau
président joe biden 46e président des
états unis
on l'a vu un
joe biden c'est que kamala harris ont
tous deux prêté serment sur la bible luc
benoît à la guillaume c'est une coutume
ce serment la main levée au dessus de la
ville où une obligation dicté par la
constitution américaine
non c'est une coutume heures ce qui est
une obligation c'est le texte du serment
qui est dans la constitution
il n'ya pas se réarmer god à la fin ça
aussi c'est une tradition et donc mettre
la main sur la bible là aussi c'est une
tradition que tous les présidents ont
respecté alors ils ont le choix de quel
bible et choisissant souvent c'est une
bible familiale ou une bible voilà qu'il
ya cent ans la fois la bible de george
washington
ouais je crois que bayonne a prêté
serment sur une bible familiale sur
remonte au 19ème siècle si je me trompe
pas vers l'ancienne maintenant c'est le
speech
on est en avance les 12h01
oui alors c'est dans le planning et la
programmation de ce qui était prévu il
avait annoncé le début de son discours à
18h - 10 à 17h50 et pour l'instant on a
l'air d'être à peu près dans les temps
c'est un an d'absence et bien chier on
prévoit ce qu'il a prévu un discours un
peu long on parle évidemment tout à
l'heure de deux kamala harris qui sera
sa sa vice présidente
il consiste en quoi le rôle de
vice-président exactement philippe gelie
que va-t-elle faire un cas malin ça
consiste en une seule chose en général
c'est d'être prêt à prendre la relève
quand le président est incapable
d'assumer ses fonctions
en l'espèce elle va avoir un rôle très
important au sénat puisque le sénat et /
moitié 50 sénateurs démocrates 50
républicain donc comme elle est
présidente par la fonction de
vice-présidente présidente du sénat elle
va être la voix de majorité surtout les
beautés important d'être la première
personne vous présenter officiellement
le 40ème président des états unis joseph
herbe hayden junior
[Applaudissements]
robert g la vice-présidente harris le
speaker et de ses leaders comme un
leader mcconnell et présidente peines
chers invités concitoyens nous célébrons
aujourd'hui le jour de l'amérique de la
démocratie un jour d'histoire les
d'espoir de renouvellement et de
résolutions à travers le creuset des
siècles l'amérique a toujours été testés
mais s'est toujours montrée à la hauteur
des défis
je ne célébrons le triangle pas de
candidat mais d'une cause la cause de la
démocratie le peuple à volonté du peuple
a été entendu nous avons appris une fois
de plus la démocratie est précieuse la
démocratie est fragile alors nous
parlons chers amis la démocratie a
remporté la partie
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui ce lieu sacré il ya quelques
jours encore la violence a essayé
d'ébranler les frais les fondations
mêmes de notre pays nous sommes ensemble
une nation sous le regard de dieu
indivisible pour procéder à une
passation pacifique de pouvoir comme
celle qu'elle c'est le cas depuis plus
de deux siècles
alors où nous regardons vers l'avenir à
7,9 à la façon qui est habituel pour les
américains nous sommes optimistes oui
nous savons que nous pouvons être ce
pays que nous pouvons redevenir ce pays
que nous sommes nous pouvons être je
tiens à remercier le vice président
simplice président qui est que devant
moi je le remercie en tout cas et je
connais la résistance la résilience de
notre constitution est la force qui est
celle de notre nation comme le cône
également présents cartes ar kg par hier
qu'ils pouvaient pas être parmi nous
aujourd'hui mais que je tiens à saluer
pour les services éminents qui l'a rendu
à notre pays je viens de prêter un
serment de façon solennelle et sacré
comme l'ont fait les autres prises avant
moi commencer par george washington mais
l'histoire américaine dépend pas d'un
seul d'entre nous ou de quelques-uns
d'entre nous mais elle dépend de nous
tous de nous le peuple qui recherchons à
parfaire notre union
nous sommes une nation extraordinaire
nous sommes de bonnes personnes à
travers les siècles
nous avons avancé malgré les difficultés
partant de paix par temps de guerre et
nous avons beaucoup avancé mais il reste
tant à faire un
nous allons continuer à avancer
rapidement car il ya beaucoup de choses
que nous devons faire pour réparer pour
restaurer pour guérir et beaucoup à
gagner eux dans les stands entre pays
ont rencontré deux de plus grande
difficulté que nous aujourd'hui avec ce
virus
silencieux qui a tuer autant de
personnes en un an que l'américain
l'amérique n'en a perdus pendant
l'ensemble de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
des millions d'emplois ont été perdus
des centaines d'entreprises ont fermé
appelle justice raciale nous vient de
400 ans d'histoire est en train de nous
faire de nous émouvoir de nous faire
avancer et ce rêve ne
sera ne saurait être retarder plus
longtemps
un cri un appel qui ne pourraient pas
être plus d'espérer qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui
la montée de l'extrémisme politique la
suprématie oui lange le terrorisme
domestique que nous devons vaincre et
que nous vaincrons
[Applaudissements]
il y aura des défis mais restaurer l'âme
de l'amérique que ce n'est pas
simplement se payer de mots cela exige
d'avoir cette chose qui est la plus
difficile peut-être à avoir dans une
démocratie l'unité en janvier nikon a
signé la déclaration d'émancipation
lorsqu'il a pris la plume
il a dit si mon nom reste dans
l'histoire ce sera pour ceux ci et toute
mon âme est dans ce document toute mon
âme
aujourd'hui en janvier aussi et bien
toute mon âme dans cet objectif unifiée
réconcilier les américains et je demande
à tous les américains de se joindre à
moi pour faire avancer cette cause venir
pour combattre les ennemis qui sont les
nôtres
la haine la colère l'extrémisme le non
respect du droit
la maladie le chômage
si nous sommes unis nous pouvons faire
de très grandes choses
réparer des injustices redonner de bon
sens plat au chant enseigner à nos
enfants dans des écoles sécurisé
[Musique]
surmonter l'épidémie faire en sorte que
la sécurité sociale couvre tout le monde
nous pouvons refaire des états unis une
fois de plus la grande force du bien
dans le monde
je sais que parler d'unité peut sembler
un peu une parole de ravers aujourd'hui
les difficultés qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui son réel certes mais elles
ne sont pas neuves toute notre histoire
c'est ce combat entre ses idéaux
américains que nous avons tous jouent
tous été créés égaux et la réalité
c'est-à-dire racisme nativisme plugger
démonisation diabolisation qui depuis
longtemps cherche à nous diviser
c'est une stat débat ou un combat
éternel et la victoire n'est jamais
certaine est la grande dépression la
première la deuxième mondiale en
septembre
nos qualités ont toujours prévalu à
chaque fois il y avait suffisamment
d'américains qui était prêt à relever le
défi à se battre et nous pouvons le
refaire aujourd'hui une histoire la fois
la raison nous montre la voie la voie de
l'unité pouvons nous voir les uns les
autres n'ont pas comme adversaire mais
comme voisins nous traitaient les uns
les autres avec dignité et respect nous
pouvons nous unir unir nos forces à
arrêter de crier faire baisser la
température
car sans unité il n'y a pas de baisse
seulement de l'amertume et de la fureur
pas de progrès simplement une colère qui
nous épuise pas de paix véritable mais
le chaos
c'est le moment que nous vivons ce sont
les difficultés que nous connaissons et
l'unité est la solution et nous devons
faire face à ce moment en tant que les
états unis d'amérique
si nous le faisons je vous garantis que
nous naissons
pas nous n'avons jamais jamais jamais
échoué aux états unis nous avons
toujours agi ensemble et de la même
façon aujourd'hui à l'heure que nous
vivons au lieu où nous sommes commençons
ici nous nous commençons à nous ré
écouter les uns les autres à nous
entendre de nouveau les uns les autres à
nous voir à la nous respecter les uns
les autres
la politique ne doit pas forcément être
une guerre nous détruisons tout sur
notre passage nous devons rejeter la
culture une culture dans laquelle les
faits eux mêmes sont minables manipuler
quand ils ne sont pas inventés chers
concitoyens
nous devons prouver que nous sommes
différents de ceux là l'amérique est
différente de ceux là bien meilleurs que
ceux là je le crois vraiment regarder le
lieu où nous sommes
le dôme qui a été parachevée pendant la
guerre civile alors que l'union était si
grièvement en péril
et pourtant le dôme a été construit nous
avons survécu
regardez le panorama quai devant moi ou
le docteur free martin luther king nous
a parlé de son rêve où il y a des
décennies les américains ont essayé
d'empêcher des femmes qui demandait le
droit de vote de manifester et
aujourd'hui nous avons avec nous
la première vice-présidente femmes des
états unis adam kamala harris ne me
dites pas que les choses ne peuvent pas
changer
linton où sont enterrés nos héros et
nous sommes nous ici quelques jours
après qu'un groupe
de séditieux à essayer donc employer la
violence pour faire taire la voix du
peuple pour nuire à la démocratie pour
nous faire sortir de ce territoire de ce
lieu sacré ça n'est pas possible ça
n'arrivera pas jamais ni aujourd'hui ni
demain ni demain ni jamais tous ceux qui
ont soutenu campagne je suis honoré du
soutien que vous avez placée vous m'avez
accordée et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
soutenu
je vous dirais la chose suivante faites
nous confiance et si vous êtes toujours
en désaccord avec moi lorsque vous aurez
vu ce que je fais et bien c'est cela les
états unis c'est cela la démocratie le
droit d'être en désaccord pacifiquement
c'est peut-être notre plus grande force
mais entendez la chose suivante
le désaccord ne doit pas mener à la
désunion et je vous fais la promesse
suivante je serai un président pour tous
les américains tous les américains
je vous promets que je me battrai autant
pour ceux qui ne m'ont pas soutenu que
pour ceux qui m'ont soutenu bien des
siècles à saint-augustin c1 2010 a écrit
que le pape était une petite hutte
défini par le geiq commun de son amour
défini par l'objet commun son amour quel
est notre objet commun d'amour qu'est ce
qui nous définit en tant qu'américain je
crois que nous avons eu l'opportunité
les chances la sécurité la dignité le
respect l'honneur et oui également la
vérité ça mais nous avons appris une
leçon
rue de leçons il ya la vérité et il ya
des mensonges que l'on raconte par ma
liste pour le profit et c'est l'honneur
et le devoir des leaders politiques de
défendre la vérité et de vaincre le
mensonge
[Applaudissements]
alors je comprends que beaucoup de mes
concitoyens sont pessimistes par rapport
à l'avenir
ils craignent pour leur emploi ils se
demandent s'ils vont pouvoir payer
l'assurance maladie leur hypothèque
ils pensent à leur famille se demande de
quoi l'avenir sera fait sachez que je
comprends votre situation
mais la réponse à cela n'est pas
l'europe le repli sur soi même
la méfiance à l'égard de ceux qui ne
vous ressemble pas ou ont d'autres dieux
où vivent différemment de vous nous
devons mettre fin à cette guerre civile
nous divisent conservateurs quatre
progressistes démocrates contre
républicains nous pouvons le faire si
nous ouvrons notre coeur si nous faisons
preuve d'un peu de tolérance et
d'humilité ici nous sommes prêts à nous
mettre à la place de l'autre comme dit
ma mère parfois mais toi dans les dents
dans les chaussures comme on dit en
anglais mais toi à la place de l'autre
parce que dans la vie on ne peut pas
savoir ce qui peut nous arriver un jour
un jour on a besoin on en aura besoin
dead est un autre jour on sera appelée à
aider l'autre c'est normal c'est ce que
font les êtres humains les uns pour les
autres et si nous nous conduisons de la
sorte notre pays sera plus fort plus
prospère
plus près affrontait l'avenir et nous
pourrons continuer à être en désaccord
concitoyens dans le travail que nous
allons devoir accomplir ensemble nous
aurons besoin de toutes nos forces nous
aurons besoin les uns des autres pour
surmonter ce terrible hiver
le pic de l'épidémie
cela nous devons le faire cette bataille
nous devons la livrer ensemble en tant
que nation une nation unie et je vous
promets la chose suivante
comme dit la bible qu'est la nuit
peut-être dur mais ensemble nous allons
vers un matin meilleur
nous saurons le faire ensemble tous mes
collègues du sénat de chambre des
représentants et qui ont servi avec moi
nous comprenons tous la chose suivante
le monde est en train de regarder ce qui
se passe aux etats unis aujourd'hui est
donc voila mon message pour ceux qui
vivaient à l'extérieur de nos frontières
qu'america l'amérique a connu une
épreuve mais en est sorti plus fort que
nous allons réparer nos alliances et re
dialoguer avec le monde pas pour
répondre au dif des figuiers armée aux
défis d'aujourd'hui et de demain et on
seront leaders pas seulement par la
puissance mais par l'exemple partenaire
fort et respecté pour la paix le progrès
la sécurité vous le savez et je vais
vous demander à ce titre de vous joindre
à moi pour un moment de prière adressée
à ce que nous avons perdu ces derniers
mois
ces quatre cent mille concitoyens amis
collègues membres de nos familles nous
allons les honorer en redevenant ce
peuple que nous savons pouvoir être et
dont je vous demande de faire avec moi
une prière silencieuse pour ceux que
nous avons perdus et pour notre pays lui
même
fox vivons une épreuve la démocratie et
la vérité sont attaqués l'épidémie fait
rage de les inégalités le racisme
systémique le climat aux états unis dans
le monde
un seul de ces défis serait isolément
déjà suffisamment immense mais le fait
qu'ils se présentent tous simultanément
nous met face à l'une des plus graves
responsabilités que nous ayons jamais
connue en tant que pays
allons nous relever ces défis
il est temps d'être audacieux parce
qu'il ya tant à faire et ce qui est
certain je vous le promets c'est que
nous serons jugés vous et moi
à l'aune de notre capacité à résoudre
cette cascade de défi de difficultés
tout capacité à maîtriser ses
difficultés notre capacité à transmettre
à nos enfants un meilleur pays un
meilleur monde et je suis persuadé comme
vous l'êtes j'en suis sûr que nous en
sommes capables
et quand nous l'aurons le fait nous
écrirons le nouveau le prochain chapitre
extraordinaire de l'histoire américaine
une histoire ressemble peut-être à cette
chanson qui signifie temps pour moi
l'hymne américain il y a il vous plaît
qui est tout à fait remarquable pour moi
en tout cas et c'est celui qui dit la
chose suivante le travail et les prières
des siècles nous ont amenés jusqu'à ce
jour ce qui sera notre héritage que
diront nos enfants je voudrais savoir
dans mon coeur quand mes jours seront
talent à leur terme
quelle est la réponse à cette question
amérique amérique j'ai donné le meilleur
de moi même pour toi
ajoutons donc aujourd'hui nos propres
travail nos propres travaux nos propres
prières à ceux
à cette immense tâche et si nous le
faisons quand nous parviendrons à long
terme de nos existences nos enfants
diront de nous ils ont fait de leur
mieux ils ont accompli leur devoir ils
nous ont fait avancer vers la terre
promise dames et messieurs chers
concitoyens
solennellement je tiens à vous le
promettre je défendrai notre
constitution
notre démocratie l'amérique et je
donnerai vous tous l'opportunité la
possibilité de progresser et ensemble
nous écrirons cette histoire de lumière
et non de ténèbres de décence de dignité
d'amour de guérison de grandeur et de
bonté que cette histoire soit celle qui
nous guide qui nous inspire l'histoire
qui dira aux générations à venir que
nous avons répondu à l'appel de
l'histoire que nous avons été à la
hauteur du moment la démocratie l'espoir
la vérité la justice ne sont pas morts
sous votre houlette mais au contraire se
sont développées et donc avec cet espoir
et avec cette détermination nous allons
avancer vers ces objectifs
soutenus par la foi et notre amour du
pays
que dieu bénisse les états unis
d'amérique et que dieu protège nos
troupes
merci
à mes concitoyens le discours tant
attendu le discours d'investiture de joe
biden un discours qui est finalement au
niveau du timing dans l'étang de ce qui
avait été prévu c'est à dire que je
crois qu'il a fait un peu plus d'une
vingtaine de minutes
philippe gelie qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé de ce discours qui a balayé
un certain nombre de thèmes et qui a mis
en avant à la fois le pays mais aussi la
personne de joe biden qui à plusieurs
reprises a fait référence à sa personne
à son âme à sa mère oui joe biden c'est
que c'est un vieux monsieur qui avait
vécu beaucoup de choses dans la
politique américaine mais qui est très
très authentique et ce discours c'était
lui c'est à dire c'était pas très
enflammé ce n'était pas une rhétorique
très anglais est très très enlevé ce
n'était pas non plus très écrit j'ai
trouvé mais c'était sincère il y avait
un ton de prêche qui souligna mais à mon
avis le l'ampleur des défis c'est à dire
qu'on le sent quand même un peu
impressionnés par la cascade des filles
dans jeu qu'il a cité les ce discours
pour résumer pour moi c'est byden sur
deux plans l'empathie et les principes
et c'est un homme qui se définit par ces
deux par ces deux repères si je puis
dire lé principe c'est la démocratie
la vérité et l'unité et voilà tous les
défis qu'il a énumérés que ce soit bien
sûr la lutte contre le coc vide mais
surtout les divisions profondes de la
société américaine
il entend essayer de les résoudre
avec ces trois principes de démocratie
de vérité d'unités alors qu'on entend en
ce moment à l'interprétation d'une
chanson que je croyais aussi un
classique américain par le chanteur de
country music garth brooks
je vous pose également la même question
avoue également ligue benoît à la
guillaume qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé de ce discours vous qui avez en
tête et qui est l'auteur d'une thèse
disco et oui je suis d'accord que le ton
de prêches bon qui est en fait pas si
rare que ça parce que c'est
fondamentalement ce type de discours
c'est l'éloge de la nation et de ses
valeurs donc il ya toujours un ton de
valeurs morales alors ici qui est quand
même plus présent que d'habitude avec la
prière silencieuse autant que je me
souvienne il ya un précédent seulement
eisenhower en 57 avait fait une prière
au début de son discours
mais aller jusqu'à introduire une prière
dans le discours c'est quand même pas si
courant que ça dans ce type de discours
mais par contre effectivement le l'éloge
des valeurs de la nation
c'est un c'est un grand classique avec
évidemment à la fois l'appel à l'unité
et puis dans les valeurs qui sont
indiqués quand même un rejet à la fois
de la violence politique et du mensonge
qui ça n'est pas dit comme ça mais c'est
quand même implicite caractéristiques de
la présidence précédente parce que c'est
quand même une manière de rejeter ce
qu'il y avait avant
il ya aussi dans ce discours comme
souvent un peu un pot-pourri d'
influence précédent projet mentionné la
prière de 57 où on peut penser que les
ceux qui ont écrit ont été recherchés ce
qui s était fait avant de prier en
mettant
contraint d'entendre amazing grace et
interprété par garth brooks
il ya aussi un emprunt à la cérémonie
dregan en 81 il ya un moment où il est
sûr puisque donc il est soumis sont sur
le côté ouest la de ces depuis 80 que
c'est comme ça et donc on a tout le
paysage de de la donc dit voilà le dôme
qui est bon voilà le panorama voilà le
cimetière d'arlington
et en fait ça c'est toute la conclusion
du discours de reggane en 81
en coproduction avec la télé à chaque
fois il ya un gros plan sur les
monuments pour faire vibrer le
patriotisme américain en montrant ses
grands monuments
donc ça c'était quelque chose qui voilà
qui visiblement a été repris en plus
court de ce qui avait été fait il ya 40
ans merci il a respecté votre script
puisqu'il a dit mot pour mot je serai le
président de tous les américains
ouais mais ça aurait dit on voit ça
c'est oui merci benoît à la guillaume
pour votre analyse de ce discours donc
c'était amazing grace un cantique
chrétiens interprété par le chanteur
extrêmement populaire aux états unis qui
est un chanteur de country music une
cour sur l'estrade là en ce moment
visiblement très heureux qu'est ce que
disent ce discours de joe biden de son
futur mandat
est ce que l'on peut déjà analysé un peu
et comment se comportera joe biden il a
compris que tout sens qu'il s'engagera
sur les défis concrets qui l'attend
économiques sanitaires sociaux réformer
le système de santé etc
rien ne marchera s'il n'obtient pas un
minimum de consensus dans le pays et on
le sent très conscients de cet enjeu de
ce défi là mais pas du tout certain
de d'y arriver or c'est un préalable si
vous voulez s'il se heurte comme par
exemple obama le jour de l'investiture
d'obama il y avait une réunion au
congrès juste après cette cérémonie de
tous les dirigeants républicains de la
chambre et du sénat qui ont pris ce
jour-là une décision politique
stratégique de s'opposer à tout ce que
proposerait obama obama a passé sa
réforme de la santé
les deux premières années de son mandat
ah parce qu'il avait la majorité sans
une seule voix des républicains
et tout le reste de son mandat il n'a
rien pu faire passer hayden a vécu ça en
tant que vice président il sait très
bien quelle est la capacité de blocage
du congrès avec une majorité qui est
plus étroite que celles de la précédente
chambre et un équilibre sur le fil au
sénat avec juste la voix de la vice
présidente qui va d'ailleurs dû de ce
fait passer beaucoup de temps au sénat
donc il a besoin d'arriver à une forme
de consensus minimal avec des gens comme
mitch mcconnell qui l'a invité à
l'accompagner à la messe pour arriver à
faire passer les réformes de fond qu'il
veut faire passer
on est en train de voir à l'image
l'intervention d'une jeune femme de 23
ans une poétesse afro américaine du nom
d'amanda gorman et qui est en train de
lire sa propre création sont propres
poèmes intitulé 2008 lime la commune de
la colline que nous gravissons pour
finalement se retrouver à réciter un
poème
nous avons 100 vers une union parfaite
je ne sais pas nous avançons vers une
union qui a des désirs qui souhaite
qu'ils aspirent à réunir tous les hommes
et donc nous regardons non pas ce qui
nous divise mais ce qui est deux ans
nous
nous comblons le fossé car nous savons
mettre notre avenir avant toute autre
chose
nous ne voulons malice à personne nous
voulons l'harmonie pour nous et le monde
[Musique]
malgré la douleur nous avons espoir
nous rêvons nous espérons que nous
serons toujours liés les uns aux autres
victorieux non pas parce que nous ne
connaîtrons jamais la défaite mais
victorieux parce que plus jamais nous ne
s'aimeront la division si nous sommes à
la hauteur de l'époque la victoire ce
sera d'abord les ponts les passerelles
que nous aurons su construire car être
américain c'est plus qu'une fierté
hérité c'est le passé ces jolis mots
belles paroles de la poétesse amanda
gorman je vais devoir rendre sa liberté
à philippe gelie merci encore philippe
gelie d'avoir éclairé nos internautes
sur cette cérémonie d'investiture qui a
permis l'élection qui a vu l'élection
définitive et l'investiture du 46e
président des états unis joe biden et
son sa vice-présidente camélat kamala
harris je vous laisse partir parce que
vous avez l'édito a terminé pour le
papier de demain et la version très
faiblement sur le site du figaro je
précise que ce joyeux se joindra à cet
édito dans les pages du figaro il y aura
un gros dossier
six à dix principes âge de vingt six
pages demain encore le print sur cette
investiture globale sur le site interne
et beaucoup de choses évidemment sur
lefigaro.fr et 6 pour les abonnés du
figaro premium merci encore philippe
gibert sciemment on peut réécouter de
nouveau cette poétesse afro américaine
amanda gorman farouche libre qui ne se
laisse pas intimider
une chose est certaine si la wii merci
la miséricorde est le pouvoir se
conjuguent
alors l'amour deviendra notre héritage
et transformera la vie ainsi une gravi
la colline de notre histoire de notre
géographie nous reconstruirons nous
réconcilierons nous guérirons notre
nation dans ses moindres recoins dans
toute sa beauté sa diversité sortiront
de l'ombre de la peur pour aller vers la
lumière de l'épanouissement la lumière
existent toujours
si l'on est suffisamment courageux pour
la voir et pour être cette lumière
[Applaudissements]
voilà comme je vous le disais on vient
d'entendre donc cette poétesse amanda
gorman lire son poème de wickline la
colline que nous gravissons et
maintenant je crois qu'il s'agit du
révérend nous allons assister à la
bénédiction par le pasteur sylvester
beamon
en tant que nation
gab deux fois une sonde dans la prière
dieu nous nous réunissons sous la beauté
de tonte à saint tite est hélas entité
de ta beauté
nous recherchons ton visage ton sourire
te demandons une fois de plus d'accorder
ta faveur à notre président et notre vie
du président c'est que leur famille te
demandons également d'étendre la même
faveur vice-présidente son mari à sa
famille
plus que jamais que jamais ils ont
besoin de toi comme notre nation a
besoin de toi nous avons besoin de
l'histoire seigneur 40 doit nous
découvrons notre commune humanité dans
notre commune humanité nous irons
trouver les blessés pour panser leurs
plaies trouveront la guérison pour ceux
qui sont malades nous porteront le deuil
de nos morts nous seront données de
l'amitié à ceux qui sont solitaires ou
désespéré la justice pour ceux qui sont
pressés nous reconnaîtrons le fait chez
nous chercherons le partons ce qui nous
permettra d'avancer vers la
réconciliation découvrir notre humanité
nous permettra de trouver ce qu'il ya de
bon dans chacun de nos voisins des mêmes
se semble ne pas pouvoir être aimé
libérés les parias de tous les stigmates
attendre les opportunités à ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas deviendront les amis de
nos ennemis ne nous seront les amis de
nos ennemis que jamais nous ne le
verrons les armes les impôts les contres
les autres que nous utiliserons toutes
nos ressources pourrait aider les deux
sauté si j'y ai beau de lumière pour le
monde entier
nous vivrons dans l'appel de façon à ne
pas causer de frayeur à nos voisins et
au delà de toutes différences raciales
géographique personnel nous deviendrons
de meilleur gardien de ton environnement
préservant la tare en dégageant une
moisson durable pour le bien des
générations
c'est cela notre bénédiction que sur
cette terre sacrée par le passé ont
travaillé des esclaves des amérindiens à
ceux qui viennent d'être naturalisé des
immigrants du passé je n'eus d'europe et
du reste du monde de tous les êtres
humains quel que soit leur choix
un choix de vie nous disons que ce sont
les enfants de dieu ta gloire ta majesté
la puissance et on pouvoir pour toujours
je dit 'alleluia' loire alléluia au nom
si puissant de notre foi collective
amen voilà c'était l'intervention du
pasteur sylvester beeman qui est en fait
pasteur dans une des églises de
wilmington dans le delaware qui est en
fait la ville de résidence de joe biden
désormais 46e président des états unis
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
connaissent pas ou qui connaissent mal
joe biden et ben je vous propose de
regarder un sujet en tout cas c'est une
rencontre et une interview de renault
toffee avec la biographe de joe biden
sonia dridi
on écoute avec nous bonjour vous avez
écrit joe biden le pari de l'amérique en
titre up aux éditions du rocher et vous
revenez sur sa vie largement dans ce
livre alors justement première question
quels sont les épisodes de la vie de joe
biden qu'il faut absolument connaître
pour mieux cerner sa personnalité pense
que l'un des premiers événements
marquants de sa vie notamment lorsqu'il
était jeune et bien c'est que s'il était
bègue et du coup ça lui a valu beaucoup
de moqueries notamment de la part d'une
religieuse puisqu'il était dans une
école catholique qui moquaient lui un
jour et ça a beaucoup énervé sa maman
qui a un caractère bien trempé comme by
donne d'ailleurs il puisque ils sont
d'origine irlandaise il parle de irish
times peur et donc sa maman a débarqué
dans l'école et à dix à la bonne soeur
si vous remontez de moscou depuis c'est
bien je vais vous enlevez ce votre fichu
de votre tête et je pense que c'est cet
événement a marqué joe biden et surtout
ça c'est une première preuve de ça
immense résilience de sa persévérance
parce que à force de s'exercer devant le
miroir tous les soirs et bien il a
combattu son bégaiement et d'ailleurs
depuis il donne souvent des conseils aux
personnes bègues donc je pense que ça a
été vraiment un événement marquant de
son enfance ensuite il ça comme était
l'un des sénateurs les plus jeunes de
l'histoire américaine à être élu il a
été élu à 29 ans et quelques semaines
après cet immense victoire
et bien ça a été le drame puisqu'il a
perdu sa première femme et lia et leur
petite fille de 13 mois dans un accident
de voiture ses deux fils ont survécu
mais évidemment ça a été mis pour joe
biden il dit même avoir pensé au suicide
il a même pensé aussi abandonner son
siège au sénat pour être auprès de ses
deux fils hunter est beau et finalement
et bien il a il a passé 36 ans au sénat
dans au sénat vous venez de le dire est
une trajectoire de vie qui a suscité
énormément d'empathie auprès des
américains alors justement avec son
parcours avec les drames qu'il a vécu à
quel type de président doit-on
s'attendre à partir d'aujourd'hui aux
états unis tout à fait je pense que vous
avez employé le mot juste ce qui marque
chez chez joe biden est ce qu'on a vu
surtout pendant cette campagne c'est sa
grande empathie on a vu cela
surtout en contrepoint par rapport à son
prédécesseur parce que notamment que
lorsqu'il a eu ses crises il ya toujours
ces cris cette crise économique et cette
crise du coc vide
et bien c'est vrai que joe biden a su
employer les bons mots le ton juste et
on sent qu'il ait quitté par la
population même par les républicains
notamment les républicains les plus
modérés parce qu'en fait comme on le
surnomme ici c'est oncle john tout le
monde connaît l'histoire de joe biden
sait aujourd'hui un peu comme le vieux
grand-père america dondon finale manquée
toute l'histoire est très connu par par
la population et c'est vrai que il est
aussi connu pour avoir plusieurs fois au
cours de sa carrière donné son numéro de
téléphone personnel à des gens qui
venaient de traverser des g et donc
c'est vrai que son empathie je pense va
marquer sa présidence et je pense que
finalement cet homme qui a été un
candidat par défaut qui a vraiment pas
soulevé l'enthousiasmé
auprès des démocrates et notamment des
plus jeunes
finalement il apparaît presque l'homme
de la situation parce que l'amérique est
frappé par des crises très importantes
comme vient de le dire économique
sanitaire et donc finalement c'est
peut-être à un moment où les américains
ont envie d'un président un peu plus
normales voire ennuyeux mais avec
beaucoup d'empathie
oui et justement sa dynamique de
campagne reposait sur cette idée de
réconciliation d'une amérique fracturée
mais ce qu'à 78 ans sonia il a encore
les épaules et le charisme pour porter
ce combat
alors je pense comme vous l'avez dit on
est vraiment une nouvelle ère d'ailleurs
ça ça chagrine beaucoup de joe biden lui
et d'autres élus démocrates sont tandis
qu'on est vraiment une époque où la
pollinisation extrêmes et c'est plus
justement comme l'époque de joe biden ou
après le après certaines cessions ils
allaient boire des verres avec des
sénateurs républicains y arriver à
discuter c'est vrai que là il y à une
polarisation extrême donc ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué et je pense peut
il
ça va être un défi immense pour joe
biden et sur certains sujets sensibles
il n'y aura pas d'accord avec les
républicains et je pense que les
républicains vont quand même lui mettre
des bâtons dans les roues mais je pense
qu'on peut arriver avec dubai donne un
certain apaisement
parce qu'on l'a vu déjà au moment de
l'invasion du capitole alors qu'il
devait être certes si sa victoire devait
être a été certifié et bien les
républicains les élus républicains les
plus modérés les plus traditionnelles
qui connaissent bien joe biden ont tenu
malgré l'invasion du capitole à revenir
et à aa a certifié la victoire de joe
biden alors évidemment parce qu'ils
veulent défendre la démocratie et
c'était très important pour ne pas se
laisser abattre
après cette attaque mais c'est aussi
parce que ils connaissent ce joe biden
et je pense que il ya eu encore une fois
il ya une certaine affection pour
l'homme qu'il est parce que tout le
monde le connaît très bien et ce qui ne
veut pas dire que du jour au lendemain
la mairie va être réconciliées que les
jambons et que les élus républicains
devront arriver à travailler ensemble
mais s'il ya bien une personne je pense
qu'il peut apporter cet apaisement
c'est joe biden il a été aussi le
fidèle vice-président de barack obama
pendant huit ans comment d'après vous il
va jouer de cet héritage politique qui
peut être aussi un peu à double
tranchant oui complètement quand on voit
barack obama à côté de joe biden ça
rappelle que tu pas que joe biden manque
de charisme que c'est un candidat du
passé c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que la
jeune génération était vraiment déçu
d'avoir un candidat comme joe biden et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que son équipe
est assez sensible sur ce sujet j'ai
notamment parlé à tony blinken le futur
secrétaire d'état qui m'a dit il ya
quelques mois nous ne referons pas du
obama on voit par exemple un joe biden
est beaucoup plus dur à l'égard de
l'arabie saoudite est également dit
serait le grand allié des états unis
collègues alors que sous la période
obama et bien il y avait toujours de
bonnes relations et là sous la pression
des démocrates les plus progressistes de
l'ailé gauche et bien joe biden on le
voit sur sur certains sujets politique
étrangère est un peu plus dure on sait
aussi que il a le camp lille a eu un
programme pendant cette campagne le plus
à gauche du parti démocrate
et je pense que l'un des défis de joe
biden en plus de réponses et les
américains ça va être finalement de
calmer un petit peu cette halle gauche
en tout cas de travailler avec cet album
parce que finalement le parti démocrate
est aujourd'hui très divisée merci
beaucoup sonia merci à vous merci
beaucoup
renault toffee pour cet entretien avec
notre consoeur sonia dridi biographe de
joe biden elle
de faire paraître un ouvrage joe biden
aux éditions du rocher
on accueille maintenant renaud girard on
est très heureux de vous accueillir
renault gérard vous êtes grand reporter
et chroniqueur au service international
du figaro et spécialiste des questions
stratégiques
vous l'avez évidemment entendu ce
discours d'investiture de joe biden bien
qu'en avez-vous pensé
c'est un discours comme centriste modéré
c'est un discours placé sur le thème de
l'unité c'est très important vous avez
vu qu'il a pris le la remercier le
vice-président peines d'être là il a dit
qu'ils seraient le président de tous les
américains qui servirait aussi les
américains qui ont voté pour trump qui
sont très nombreux parce qu'en fait
autant dubai dunn a fait le plus haut
score de toute l'histoire des états unis
en nombre de suffrages
je pense que ce film j'ai bonne mémoire
c'était 77 millions de suffrages mais
trump
avec ses 70 millions de suffrages a fait
le deuxième score de l'histoire des
états unis donc il a quand même eu
beaucoup de gens qui se sont qui se sont
déplacés pour aller voter pour lui
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
vraiment l'amérique traditionnel dire
c'est là la nouvelle jérusalem les
américains ce sont des gens qui ont
quitté l'europe pour xviie siècle et
même au 18ème l'europe corrompus pour
pour avoir une nouvelle religion de
religion moins corrompus plus honnête et
et qui se considère toujours comme une
force de bien dans le monde et l'a dit
d'ailleurs nous sommes la grande force
du bien dans le monde voilà alors il ya
des gens qui peuvent peu dire c'est
peut-être sans doute vrai vous avez de
bonnes intentions
parfois quand même mais sur les
américains l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions et je ne suis pas sûr que
avec vos interventions en irak de 2003
par exemple ou même au kosovo en 1999
vous n'avez fait que du bien enfin en
tout cas en deux mais le moyen-orient
depuis l'invasion de george w bush qui a
été approuvé un parti au bail donne il
faut bien le dire pas par obama ils
étaient approuvés par joe madden qui
était sénateur il ya eu un vote amis
l'ensemble qui étaient faits au nom des
forces du bien au nom des forces la
démocratie cette invasion qui était
illégal et illégitime et illégal surtout
pas sanctionné par le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies cette
invasion a mis un immense chaos dans
tout le moyen-orient qui n'est toujours
pas qui ne joue pas mais c'était
intéressant de voir qu'il s'inscrivait
dans cette amérique religieuse un dieu a
beaucoup d'importance
les prières nous sommes sous le regard
de dieu c'est une grande différence avec
avec la france l'amérique c'est ça c'est
là une bonne which was comme des
techniques sur les billets de banque
et puisqu'il a dit aussi un peu de
sujets internationaux mais il a quand
même parler du climat donc il va revenir
dans l'accord de paris sur le climat je
serais pas d'accord avec ma collègue
sonia dridi sur ce qu'il dit sur israël
je ne pense pas qui sera je ne pense pas
d'abord que barack obama était
particulièrement pro israéliens il a
commencé son mandat de président barack
obama le premier c'était de téléphoner
au leader palestinien
des palestinien mahmoud abbas et il
s'était même engagé ce président obama à
régler le conflit israëlo palestinien en
un an
il n'y est pas arrivé il a fait un
discours du caire le 4 juin
c'était le 4 juin 2009 oui elle avait
répété cette promesse
il n'y est pas arrivé mais il a été
considéré comme très dure pas les
israéliens je ne pense pas mais je peux
me tromper évidemment que alors il sera
pas aussi pro israéliens que que trump
parce que trump c'était jared kushner
c'était voilà mais c'était vraiment la
trump est l'amie personnelle de
netanyahou etc
mais je ne pense pas qu'il va déménager
là l'ambassade américaine que trump a
mis à jérusalem est je ne pense pas
qu'ils veulent remettre assez rapide
pas de marche arrière et je ne pense pas
que les américains seront tellement plus
généreux à l'égard de des palestiniens
il souhaite certes un état palestinien
mais ce que de la obligeront ils les
israéliens à donner aux palestiniens un
état avec des sanctions des choses comme
ça je ne le crois absolument pas combien
même joe biden voudrait le faire je
pense qu'il veut pas le faire quand bien
même vous là et il le faire que le
congrès ne lui permettrait pas le nom à
la guillaume vous qui êtes historien
spécialiste des discours d'investiture
des présidents américains quand on
revient sur ce discours de joe biden
qu'on a entendu il ya quelques minutes
est ce qu'on peut considérer que ce
discours rentrera dans l'histoire ou
bien c'est le contexte sanitaire
sociétal qui a fait que cette ville de
washington aujourd'hui et et susan
espèce de chape de sécurité massive
est ce que c'est ça qui restera ou c'est
très clairement le ce discours qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure
alors bon pour être franc et sans
vouloir blesser le président mbaye donne
tout son kindle qui ne m'écoute pas je
ne pense pas que c'est un discours qui
restera dans l'histoire
il y en a très peu qui reste dans
l'histoire en vérité un
regardez dit voilà il ya kennedy il ya
franklin roosevelt dans 33 mais sinon
les autres discours sont quand même
oublier assez rapidement souvent est
celui là à mon avis bon ne sera pas
voilà ne sera ne rentrera pas dans les
histoires et celui de trump restaura
parce qu'il est le message était très
simple
certains diront simpliste ouais c'était
america ferait donc ça on se souviendra
de son message je suis d'accord avec
vous par rapport aux autres présidents
grand président démocrate ou connu en
tout cas que son roosevelt et kennedy
oui ouais mais bon par contre la
cérémonie effectivement les
circonstances voilà restera c'est je
voudrais vous poser quelques questions
d'internautes qui sont entrain nombreux
à faire part de leurs de leurs questions
et de leurs commentaires pour vous
renaud girard g alexandre sur youtube
qui dit mbaye donne redorera le blason
des états unis à l'international
après quatre ans de moqueries alors
alors on essaie d'avoir alors ce qui est
sûr c'est que sans doute il va revenir
c'est à espérer en tout cas il a une
chance pour revenir dans l'accord
nucléaire avec l'iran du 14 juillet 2015
accor de vienne qui était le grand
succès diplomatique d'obama
c'était le retour n'est ce pas de l'iran
dans l'arène internationale c'était la
réconciliation après cette affaire très
ancienne qui étaient les affaires des
otages américains en 1979 80 et alors
est ce que il arrivera à conclure avec
les iraniens
d'ici les élections en iran de juillet
2021 voilà la vraie question sera-t-il
capable de faire une diplomatie blitz
c'est à dire de dire hozjan est un
modéré parce que sur les mots d'eric qui
voulait un accord avec les américains
qui ont signé cet accord deviennent de
2015 présidents rois ni qui va s'en
aller pouvoir ils n'appellent pas le
droit de se représenter
est ce qu'il arrivera à faire un deal
avec eux
rapidement c'est à dire un deal ou les
et lysiane air renonce pour toujours aux
armes nucléaires ou réduisent leur
influence ou leur volonté d'ingérence
parce qu'on appelle l'acte sheed c'est à
dire vers le liban la syrie l'irak le
yémen
on change un peu leur programme
balistique en échange de l'abandon de
toutes les sanctions et des gels des
avoirs iraniens aux états unis
c'est à dire que l'iran pourrait devenir
la grande puissance commerciale qu'elle
était du temps du shah
c'est à voir est ce qu'il aura l'énergie
et il sera joué avec tact et doigté
parce qu'ils aient déjà ramené à son
très orgueilleux c'est à voir mais c'est
de cette grande et bien passé ça peut
faire suivent anthony blinken qui est le
secrétaire d'état de jubail affirmé hier
que washington recherchera je cite un
accord plus fort et plus durable avec
l'iran oui plus durable ça veut dire
qu'en fait l'accord signé par là mais
pas que john kerry qui va s'occuper
moment du climat c'est ce qu'on appelle
sun cette clause c'est à dire qu'en fait
les iraniens ne renonçait pas pour
toujours à l'enrichissement de l'uranium
et pour une certaine durée et là je
pense qu'ils pouvaient obtenir que les
iraniens renonce pour toujours à
l'enrichissement de l'uranium pour des
degrés militaires acquis kamala harris
et son mari disent au revoir il vient de
monter dans un véhicule officiel pour
partir
image intéressante et symbolique de ce
véhicule qui se retire et qui quittent
les marches du capitole à washington
donc c'est mike pence ex-vice-président
de donald trump qui quitte tout seul au
promet à parti républicain assez divisés
je dirais le parti légitimiste une
partie des républicains qui ont été un
peu
horrifiée par ce qu'il faut bien appeler
les dérapages les dernières semaines de
trump c'est à dire de ne pas avoir su
reconnaître qu'ils étaient quand même
attente qu'il ait demandé des enquêtes
c'est normal mais qui était quand même
patente
et puis ne pas avoir su intervenir et la
part il n'a pas appelé aux violences il
faut pas exagérer il n'a pas appelé aux
violences au capital il aurait pu dire
dès que ces violences avaient commencé
pour eux il aurait pu dire à ses
partisans on arrête quoi ce qui n'a pas
fait de violence on a souvent reproché à
donald trump sa brutalité dans ses
rapports diplomatiques avec l'étranger à
maroc sur youtube demande la politique
diplomatique de bayonne sera t-elle plus
douce que celle de donald trump
alors je ne crois pas du tout que par
exemple ça sera meilleure pour nous
européens je crois pas du tout qu'il
faut se faire des illusions ou les suis
vraiment toujours ses intérêts par
exemple ils ont quelque chose savaient
ils ont ils disent que par exemple qu'on
veut nous français vendre des armes
par exemple des missiles à l'egypte et
bien ah bah vous pouvez pas parce qu'il
ya des composants américains et donc il
faut on ne peut vendre que les âmes 100%
france etc etc
je pense qu'ils sont toujours dus est
dur commercialement mais en revanche la
grande différence c'est que trump ne
croyait pas au multilatéralisme
alors que les démocrates hebeisen croit
au multilatéralisme multilatéralisme
c'est quand même le nul qui a été créée
par un grand président démocrate dont
vous avez parlé franklin delano
roosevelt et alors que trump qui venait
du milieu de des marchands de biens new
yorkais les discussions à plusieurs ils
ne comprenaient pas et comprenant m pas
même pas le principe si vous voulez et
donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que trump
s'est retirée de plusieurs accords
précieux l'accord sur l'iran dont j'ai
parlé l'accord de paris sur le climat et
un accord qui était pourtant très
bénéfique ou pause désuni qu'on appelle
le trans pacific partnership c'était un
c'était à un accord entre tous les pays
asiatiques sauve la chine
et les états unis c'était contre
évidemment contre l'asim pour avoir une
sorte de zone avec des normes éthiques
et des normes industrielles et des
normes de commerce qui puisse s'opposer
à l'hégémonisme commercial chinois et sa
part détestation pas par amour de la
chine presque trompent ils méritent
d'ailleurs à être le premier à dire aux
chinois maintenant vous arrêtez de voler
la technologie sa personne l'avait dit
avant lui même pas aux bahamas et une
mairie de 32 d'avoir osé le dire mais
trump a saboté un accord qui était très
bénéfique aux états unis qui était ce ce
partenariat transpacifique alors je
pense pas que cet accord pour deux
raisons techniques puissent être
remettre en piste tout de suite mais en
revanche il a lorsque vis-à-vis de nous
européens ce qu'il faut attendre
est-ce que s qu'abidal continuera à être
dur avec nous c'est à dire la politique
de trump on a eu quand même des on a on
a en ce moment des droits de douane
punitifs sur les vins français sur le
whisky anglais etc sur les produits
européens
est-ce que ça va continuer ou pas est ce
que joe biden et son
secrétaire d'état tenue jean kane qui
est francophile et francophone va qui
parle très bien français va va proposer
une sorte de grand à lyon de grands
traités de libre-échange amérique europe
je pense personnellement c'est
souhaitable face à la chine je pense
qu'il faut que les alliés qui partagent
les mêmes valeurs démocratiques quand
même qu'ils sont les américains et les
mêmes valeurs d'état de droit que sont
les américains et les européens et un
accord de libre échange et de normes
communes face à la puissance commerciale
chinoise est ce que byden va aller aussi
loin
ce n'est pas du tout sûr cela dépendra
bien sûr toujours aussi beaucoup du
congrès girard juste de précisions
concernant l'europe et les rapports des
états unis avec l'europe on précisera
que ursula von der leyen qui est la
présidente de la commission européenne a
dit il y à quelques temps il hier
l'europe à un ami à la maison blanche
après quatre ans de présidence trump et
l'europe proposera à joe biden un
nouveau pacte fondateur pour les
relations europe etats unis autre chose
ça bien que ça vienne cette proposition
vienne lors de la commission européenne
c'est une très bonne très bonne idée ce
pacte fondateur évidemment englobera les
questions de sécurité qui sont déjà
couvertes par l'otan mais aussi toutes
ces questions commerciales de libre
échange et de normes et de droits de
douane etc
on parlait tout à l'heure des relations
diplomatiques un peu cache un peu
brutale avec les pays étrangers vous
citiez la chine
on va parler aussi de l'engagement des
états unis dans de nouvelles guerres
hier soir dans un discours d'adieu
enregistré par donald trump il a vanté
son bilan il s'est targué fière d'être
le premier président sans nouvelle
guerre à son passif depuis des décennies
est ce que c'est on peut considérer que
c'est une réussite de son mandat et est
ce que bayonne est animé par la même
ambition de ne pas s'engager dans une
nouvelle guerre
c'est tout à fait vrai que trump n'était
pas un néoconservateur il a toujours été
réticent à l'égard de ces de ces guerres
faites au nom de la grande force du bien
dans le monde n'est ce pas et il n'a pas
du tout trempé dans cette erreur
magistrale commises par des crises dans
républicain george w bush mais approuvée
par l'ensemble de l'establishment
démocrate à l'exception de dubaï mais
qui était en fait important quant à
l'époque qui est l'invasion de l'irak de
2003 alors c'est vrai que trump
à cet égard n'a pas commis de très grave
faute stratégique est ce qu'on peut
quels sont les quelles sont les fautes
qui ont été grandes [ __ ] stratégiques
qui ont été commises dans l'histoire des
états unis
récente contemporaine eh bien il ya eu
la guerre de l'irak de george w bush
il y avait eu la guerre du vietnam
commencé en fait parquet judicieuse
suivi par johnson mais comment ces
paquets de 10 et une travers de kennedy
qui a fait une autre grave erreur de
perdre cuba en parler et puis vous avez
eu comme très grave faute aussi
c'est les présidents
wilson qui a pas réussi à faire
entériner par le sénat sont d'accord son
traité de versailles qu'il avait
lui-même négocié pendant huit mois et ça
a donné
l'amérique qui a permis le réarmement
allemand qui est arrivé à la deuxième
guerre mondiale ça ce sont des très très
grave faute stratégique qui ont changé
toute l'histoire du monde 30 n'a pas
fait de raffault stratégiques alors on
peut dire il a pas si là il a hissé
retirer du traité de paris mais les
états comme la californie en dit de
toute façon on nous nous mêmes on
applique le traité de paris
c'est pas des grave faute stratégique
l'on peut dire vous pouvez dire qu'il a
que d'autres auraient peut-être pu mieux
combattre la maladie je n'en sais rien
c'est un peu technique est ce qu il a
fait des graves fautes stratégique on
peut dire que peut-être qu'effectivement
les américains avaient une sorte de
leadership encore morale encore assez
important malgré cet échec de la guerre
de 2003 mais mais en fait ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que la politique
étrangère de tram c'est la continuation
de la politique d'obama c'est obama qui
retire les forces d'irak
c'est obama qui en fait n'est pas
vraiment intervenu dans le pacifique et
donc s'est fait prendre toute la mer de
chine méridionale par les chinois si
vous voulez c'est un échec d'obama
donc il a été pendant je crois que le
grand différence le grand mérite de
trump si vous lui en trouver un
alors pour nous européens le grand le
grand des fonds le grand défaut c'est
d'avoir refusé le multilatéralisme et
c'est une très grande valeur et nous
sommes très peu nous les français très
grande valeur créée par les américains
par par roosevelt l'onu ça c'est son
grand défaut en politique étrangère sont
mérite quand même c'est certain c'était
le premier à parler durement aux chinois
mais avec réalisme c'est à dire de dire
aux chinois
vous arrêtez de voler et avec un pompe
bio par exemple sur secrétaire d'état
qui c'est vrai par exemple a pris des
positions courageuses pour protéger
c'est tout à fait naturel
la démocratie taïwanaise c'est le
dernier acte de la diplomatie trump
c'est de dire il n'y a plus aucune
limite à nos relations institutionnelles
avec taiwan si un ministre vallée à
taïwan un ministre américain il ira
taiwan quoi qu'en disent les hiérarques
de pékin et ça c'est vrai sur la chine
et je pense d'ailleurs vous verrez que
byden ne va pas du tout changé la
politique de des états unis à l'égard de
la chine mise en place par trump
donc il marchera on va dire dans l'est
pas oui ça va plus loin en tout cas il
fera pas de marche arrière comme on l'a
vu tout à l'heure le benoît à la
guillaume on va conclure cette émission
avec vous vous êtes je le rappelle
l'historien spécialiste des discours
d'investiture des présidents américains
vous avez suivi
7 cette cérémonie est très particulière
qu'est ce que vous en avez gardé
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on en garde de
cet événement qui marque l'histoire
américaine
bah moi ce qui m'a frappé bon outre bien
sûr le csn en masque quand même qu'ils
resteront comme des images
spectaculaires
c'est quand même c'est cet appel très
long et très inquiets à l'unité ce que
bon l'appel à l'unité l'unité nationale
c'est quand même un grand classique des
discours d'investiture mais là on sent
qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose de plus
qu'il ya une vraie inquiétude liée aux
divisions très profonde du pays est liée
à la situation au congrès et à
l'attitude des républicains lorsque les
démocrates sont au pouvoir qui sont
ramène pas coopératifs en tout cas ces
vingt dernières années et donc on sent
qu'il est tout à fait conscient de du
fait que faire passer sa politique
institutionnellement au congrès ça va
être très compliqué quoi merci beaucoup
a dit quand même comme vous l'avez
expliqué tout à leur congrès dont il
détient quand même les deux jean à le
parti démocrate de justesse de justesse
et justesse merci beaucoup lui benoît à
la guillaume pour tous vos éclairages
sur cet événement je disais historique
et de dans l'histoire américaine donc
cette investiture du 46e président des
états unis joe biden et sa vice
présidente
kamala harris on va accueillir dans
quelques secondes d'autopsié qui va nous
faire un point global de ce qui s'est
passé cet après midi et nous dira un peu
ce qu'il faut en retenir
avant d'en arriver là bas on se quitte
sur ces images en direct du capitole
avec toutes ces voitures officielles qui
vont partir quitter les lieux
on a vu aujourd'hui des personnalités du
monde de l'artiste et du monde
d'hollywood on a vu lady gaga jennifer
lopez renaud girard à ce propos c'est un
peu le retour d'hollywood à washington
la présence de stars de l'envergure de
celle qu'on a vu aujourd'hui à hollywood
a toujours été une grande puissance
démocrate et même assez généreuse
hollywood a aidé beaucoup la france
libre fait roosevelt méfiait beaucoup de
de gaulle mais ici il n'a pas réussi à
envoyer de gaulle en exil comme
gouverneur de madagascar à des projets
de roosevelt
c'est à cause de hollywood et de la
presse ibérique est de hollywood qui a
beaucoup défendu les français libres et
le général de gaulle pendant la guerre
le alors le oui hollywood a toujours été
proche des démocrates pro diversité
c'est une série je crois avec la selle
du paquet joué par omar sy etc
et puis vous avez aussi bayonne
il a quand même aussi pour lui toute la
presse puisque en fait toute la presse
tout là ce qu'on appelle la main' swing
c'est à dire la presse les grands
journaux à un classique américain new
york times washington poser grandes
chaînes cnn et bbc nbc était toute en
titrant même un degré d'ailleurs
excessif puisqu'il y avait une
par exemple au new york times il y avait
une dame qui était chargé de faire des
pages débats et temps en temps elle
voulait inviter quand même un sénateur
républicain
cette dame était viré il faudrait donc
là c'était vraiment les new york times
n'est plus est devenu un journal de
combat en titre up et la chaîne cnn est
devenue une chaîne de combat ont dit rep
nbc aussi et donc ça c'est le soutien
dont bénéficie byden il a aussi le
soutien de toutes les universités et des
fonctionnaires en fait voilà et dire à
l'instant
on vient de voir partir de georges jobé
du bush qui s'engouffre dans une voiture
on voit maintenant partir l'ancien
président des etats-unis bill clinton
accompagnée de sa femme hillary
ils vont eux-mêmes également hélas
barack obama et michelle obama qui
quitte aussi les lieux dans le monde
doivent se rendre au cimetière
d'arlington situé de l'autre côté du
fleuve qui traverse la capitale
washington dc qui le fleuve potomac
et il devrait donc faire une cérémonie
en hommage au soldat inconnu
un peu plus tard le temps qu'il
parvienne à destination
ce n'est pas très loin il faut s'y
rendre en voiture
ce défilé ce cortège de véhicules et de
grosses de gros on appelait ça 4,4 ou
suv c'est assez impressionnant on se
croirai toujours dans un fil
oui parce qu'elles sont blindées
évidemment les retraites on est on est
on est ravis de vous accueillir marge
encore pour conclure cette émission on
vous retrouve pour un dernier coup
d'oeil sur cette journée historique une
page s'est tournée aujourd'hui aux états
unis
oui ce fut le dernier jour d'une
présidence atypique imprévisible et un
peu chaotique parfois et ce 20 janvier
charlotte a presque fait oublier ces
quatre années
rocambolesque que l'on vient de vivre
parce qu au premier regard le cérémonial
paraissait normal réglé comme du papier
à musique
un tapis rouge déroulé à l'arrière de la
maison blanche donald trump qui embarque
dans un hélicoptère qui s'élève
doucement au dessus de washington qui
vient de se réveiller et puis les
prestations de serment que vous venez
d'entendre de kamala harris et de joe
biden mais pourtant un peu comme dans un
film hollywoodien un peu trop rapidement
écrit on a relevé assez vite les
anormalités du script et puis on s'est
rappelé qu en rupture avec ses
prédécesseurs donald trump n'a pas
assisté à la prestation de serment d'un
président dont il a toujours contesté la
victoire quand rupture avec la tradition
donald trump n'a pas accueilli joe biden
à la maison blanche après la prestation
de serment qu en rupture avec le passé
le national mall vous savez l'esplanade
que l'on a aperçu qui s'élance depuis le
capitole ne sera pas noir n'a pas été
noir de monde mais remplie de drapeaux
conditions sanitaires oblige c'est une
investiture anormal à tout point de vue
comme un étrange bal masqué où il manque
un invité de marque le celui qui devait
passer le témoin on retiendra aussi de
nombreuses formules 1 prononcé
aujourd'hui renault oui c'est donald
trump qui en premier à tirer la
couverture médiatique vers soi c'est une
fois n'est pas coutume bien sûr avec une
adresse vidéo enregistrée hier soir
d'abord où il s'est auto congratuler
puis il souhaite le meilleur à
l'administration byden visiblement assez
soucieux de respecter la dignité du
moment et puis aujourd'hui une formule
qui va occuper tous les commentateurs
pour des jours des semaines des mois
vous
j'irai probablement qu'il a prononcés
juste avant de s'envoler pour la floride
je le cite nous reviendrons d'une façon
ou d'une autre alors c'est un message
bien sûr adressé à ses 70 millions
d'électeurs mais pourquoi pas aussi aux
démocrates qui seraient tentés de
l'enterrer un peu trop vite
joe biden que vous vous l'avez entendu
en direct il s'est montré à la fois
souriant visiblement ému au moment de la
prestation de serment
et puis enfin apaisants dans le discours
il dit nous ne célébrons pas aujourd'hui
le triomphe d'un homme est celui d'une
cause la démocratie
et puis il a repris à son compte une
formule de lincoln pour expliquer ce que
sera son objectif premier vous l'avez
rappelé renault l'unité du pays il
dirait unifier notre pays mon âme réside
toute entière dans cette cause
extrêmement tendue oui et puis a raison
il faut pas oublier qu'il ya 14 jours le
capitole était pris d'assaut par des
centaines de supporteurs trump heist
revanchard des scènes troublantes en
plein coeur de la capitale américaine
qui sont soldées rappelons le par la
mort de cinq personnes
aujourd'hui l'amérique a mis les moyens
pour sécuriser cette cérémonie 25000
troupes de la garde nationale qui
avaient été mobilisés c'était quand même
dix fois la présence amie militaire
américaine en afghanistan
renault aujourd'hui l'amérique a remis
un coup de peinture sur sa démocratie
qui n'était plus très présentable depuis
deux semaines et aujourd'hui peut-être
s'ouvre un chapitre de réconciliation de
nombreuses figures figures républicaines
ont répondu à l'invitation de joe biden
que ce soit pour la cérémonie
d'investiture que l'on vient de vivre
ensemble ou pour la messe à laquelle il
a assisté ce matin citons par exemple
mike pence l'ancien vice présidente
donald trump ou mitch mcconnell le chef
des républicains au sénat
bref c'est un nouveau jour pour
l'amerique ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est joe biden ce matin sur twitter en
se levant et c'est lui désormais qui est
aux manettes pour opérer cet apaisement
dont il fait la promesse depuis des mois
et qui n'a jamais été aussi nécessaire
merci beaucoup pour vos photos par cette
intervention est ce résumé de la journée
en tout cas de cet événement historique
qui a été et qu'on a suivi ensemble
l'investiture de joe biden et de kamala
harris renaud girard c'est vous qui
aurez le dernier mot et pour conclure
cette émission sur ces images d'une un
débit d'une parade on a vu juste avant
aussi ce maul nationalement
couvert de ses 180 11000 drapeau qui
représentait les citoyens qui n'ont pas
pu se déplacer aujourd'hui pour assister
à cette investiture
qu'est ce que vous retenez vous de cet
événement historique de cette
investiture inédite du genre je retiens
bien avant je trouve que joe biden a
montré quand même qu'il avait on disait
qu'il était complètement gâteux et c'est
là qu'il a quand même montré de
l'énergie la sobriété
alors c'est pas un discours
effectivement historique mais c'est pas
non plus un mauvais discours c'est un
bon discours et c'est un discours qui
peut toucher le coeur des américains
philippe gelie l'a dit c'est un discours
sincère on sent là ça s'est arrêté et on
sent un homme qui veut bien faire alors
alors trucks vous croyez pas beaucoup
aux qu'ovide lui il y croit donc voilà
c'est c'est sécurisé
[Musique]
c'est la grande force du monde c'est
vraiment l'amérique morale si vous
voulez l'amérique tram c'était
l'amérique puissance et l amérique ne me
marchez pas sur les pieds
là c'est une amérique qui veut pas se
laisser ma cheville mais je suis un peu
au dessus de vous quand je suis la
nouvelle jérusalem
je suis moins convaincu que les autres
nations c'était un peu c'est un peu ça
le discours c'est un discours quand même
si vous voulez moi je suis optimiste je
prends les choses telles qu'elles sont
la seule la seule la seule chose qui me
fait un peu douter dans mon optimisme
parce que je pense que ça s'est bien
passé
c'est une histoire de voir une firme
privée interdire de twitter le président
des états unis
là c'est quand même quelque chose qui
m'a un tout petit peu interloqués
twitter c'est si vous savez c'est un
petit peu la cata qui joue à la fin de
sa vie elle a des vertus quoi est là
laissez les hommes politiques est de
taille et rolf l'enrichît en faisant
toute la politique sur twitter et
lorsque il est à l'évidence perdu que
c'est fini pour lui
une semaine on lui coupe on lui coupe le
sifflet il a pu le droit de s'exprimer
sur twitter alors est ce que c'est un
homme qui dirige une grosse société
privée qui peut empêcher le président en
exercice ou même maintenant qu'il n'est
plus au pouvoir
un homme qui a quand même réuni sur son
nom 70 millions d'électeurs de
s'exprimer
il ya un petit problème certains
considèrent à un petit problème de la
liberté d'expression c'est vraiment un
petit problème si c'est monsieur je ne
sais pas comment s'appelle le patron de
twitter j'ai oublié son nom ou si c'est
monsieur zuckerberg voilà donc c'est si
c'est monsieur d'orsay qui décide qui a
le droit de s'exprimer mais qui n'a pas
voilà c'est un vrai problème mais cela
mieux se faire voir de l'approché
balanced raciale voilà à part cela c'est
quand même je n'ai jamais cru que la
démocratie américaine a été mise en
danger par cette petite occupation du
capital ou d'ailleurs les manifestants
ont fait beaucoup moins de dégâts que
nous gilet jaune lieux sacrés français
qui est l'arc de triomphe et vole et
donc de bon j'ai pas voilà il est aussi
fait 5 morts c'était violent
j'ai toujours cru à la force de la
démocratie américaine qui est fondée sur
ce qu'on appelle les checks and balances
aux c'est à dire les contre pouvoirs
vous avez le pouvoir exécutif mais vous
avez le pouvoir du congrès et le pouvoir
judiciaire
et là vous avez bien vu que le congrès
et le pouvoir judiciaire n'avait pas du
tout entamé la voie proposée par trappe
et donc c'est ça la force de la
démocratie américaine est elle existe
toujours facile à jour cette démocratie
américaine est là tuez du bon et à
propos d'une procédure judiciaire
il est sous le coup d'un second dinkic
oui c'est une très mauvaise idée
alors qui va partir les gens
s'interrogent pourquoi on oui cette
procédure est ce que c'est pour
l'empêcher de la mode il est alors plus
si vous voulez on s'est tu ne sais pas
si vous voulez c'est pas à mon avis une
pitch est bonne parce que dans les îles
a jamais appelé à la violence
ça c'est faux vous faut relire les
tweets ce qu'on lui reproche c'est
d'avoir après à manifester et que la
manifestation ait dégénéré qui n'est
rien dit mais est ce que c'est une faute
pénale
c'est pas du tout c'est vrai c'est très
léger comme ils étaient empêchés il sera
empêchée de quoi de se présenter pour en
alors l'idée les questions qui crée
d'abord il faudrait deux tiers du sénat
et je n'y crois pas une seconde
il ya seulement 10 républicain à la
chambre des représentants sur 430
représentant en tout et des républicains
qui sont pour voter démocrate je crois
pas du tout que le sénat va l'empêcher
et l'idée c'est de l'empêcher ce serait
de l'empêcher de se représenter quatre
ans plus tard mais ça serait bon une
vraie atteinte à la liberté du vote la
liberté de la démocratie empêcher
quelqu'un pour laquelle 70 millions de
personnes se sont quand même déplacés
empêcher quelqu'un qui était qui a
obtenu le deuxième score de l'histoire
des états unis de faire de la politique
c'est un déni ça serait un déni de
démocratie je ne crois pas que ça va
arriver des buteurs
vos mandats en tout cas un nouveau
mandat présidentiel de quatre années
avec ce nouveau président 46e président
américain joe biden et sa vice
présidente
kamala harris vous avez pu suivre en
direct avec nous cet événement
historique américain
merci encore de nous avoir suivis en
direct sur figaro live et sur youtube
vous pouvez retrouvez le dossier complet
sur cette investiture dans les pages du
figaro papier de demain matin et sur le
site du figaro.fr évidemment avec des
informations enrichies sur le figaro
premium merci encore et à très bientôt
sur figaro live
[Musique]